I'll write my lyrics on parking tickets and some is to the code.
Well,
this on the application for counties of I practice,
it's like a spoke met Donald Trump.
Any froze up standing on his belly,
yell and pimps down.
How's suck on a front or great guy has a club ball.
People stop the world and make y'all motherfuckers jump off and this is my
resume slash resignation.
A ransom note with proposed legislation.
That ultimatum,
you should take it verbatim because I got to bang and pieces and you don't want
a day and flack back from our folks at home who take it soaks alone.
We pay in rental shit.
They don't keep as close to narrate into my parts.
Educate and [inaudible] is a million month.
The going on.
The first is the painting on the first one,
the weight in up your project.
Shut the JV job down in noon and don't disperse.
They wouldn't pay you as far as they could throw you.
They take you plunk in bud day.
Don't know you.
There's a turf proper Retta play with 12 Shabba read is by the Burger Kang
workers who be slapping on your pad is row sat in the back of note,
who is the COO,
the COO spell m c o,
u p and the coop.
That Paris remix of the song.
Ghetto manifesto though.
Dude,
these guys are good.
They're,
they're legit,
dude.
All their shit's legit.
Powerful.
Next smarts and joins us on the podcast.
Powerful
Nick Swardson.
Good Buddy.
Funny Comedian.
First Guy we've had on the podcast hung over like a mug from like God,
he's hurting right now.
Folks.
My powers are weak.
His powers,
he's strong.
He's weak.
When he's strong,
he doesn't even understand that.
You're fine,
dude.
You're going to be good.
Our podcast is always as sponsored by the fleshlight.
Are you serious?
Yeah,
man.
No,
dude,
that's awesome.
She's the alien one.
That's the,
yeah,
I blow out Jesus.
Yeah.
No one's fine.
Touch touches.
Fuck up your finger in it.
No,
it's cool.
It's a kind of a weird feeling.
Oh my God.
That's Pam.
Make mouths buttholes chai anonymous.
Even I did once.
I bought all the crew flashlights.
Nice.
That's awesome.
They're really good.
They're awesome to shoot loads into.
Yeah.
As I smelled,
I highly,
highly recommend it.
Scratched to shit loads and oh right.
It's right by my face.
I would never give you one that's been shot at.
Those are,
those are virgins or virgin lights.
Yeah,
but uh,
they're our sponsor for real nice.
I love you.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
You can get money off.
You Click the link.
It's like 15% off just entering Rogan and then you can beat off for cheap and
golf on the sheep son.
Dude.
Flashlights rule quite great.
As I mentioned,
it's amazing how controversial
it is,
man.
A lot of people don't like this.
Is that true?
Very unhappy about it.
No Way.
Yes,
absolutely.
What do you mean like a flashlight companies live?
Give me advice to not get involved with this.
This rubber in a compromise and pornographic man.
It's very controversial subject.
That's a weird,
it's hilarious,
isn't it?
Yeah.
It seems like it's a problem solver.
Sex is bad.
Neck pillow.
Talk about masturbation and like,
my mom never talks about Madison.
You know why?
Because people have to work and when you have to work,
you have to work with women and when you have to work with women,
you're not supposed to be talking about beating off in front of someone's wife
or someone's mom or whatever.
You can't talk like that.
You can't talk like you would talk right here.
When you're working with a bunch of people,
it's offensive.
When we live in a different reality,
I mean it's comedians.
It's just,
it's a completely,
I go home to Minnesota where I'm from and it's just completely warped.
I'm like making like AIDS,
Joe.
Thanks giving dinner.
People are like,
I'm like,
why is nobody laughing?
They're like,
what are you doing?
People are crying like,
you can't just say shit.
I know.
Terrible.
We,
we live in such a harsh world.
I know that it's also that most people are so programmed to like,
you know,
try to be polite and correct and not talk like that.
It's just one of those things.
The more you get used to it,
the more it becomes normal.
It's our normal,
our,
our offensive is when you know,
you go to someone's house and no one will swear.
Right.
It's just like,
what kind of weird conversations are we going to have?
I can't even say shit if I say Shit,
you're gonna freak out.
Like we're not going to get anything done.
And it's like you don't have to talk about like aids diarrhea or something all
the time.
You know what I mean?
But it's like some people want to talk about that.
There should be able to do it and they should not be judged.
If,
if there is blood in diarrhea occasionally and blood carries aids,
you can get aids.
Diarrhea.
Yeah.
It's informative and immature.
That's one of the worst ways to get diarrhea ever.
How'd you get it?
Oh No.
The worst ways to get aids ever rather.
Yeah,
I did a shot of AIDS.
Diarrhea.
Yeah,
that's how I got it.
You can just stay positive.
You get aids from a tanning bed.
What are you talking about?
That's what chicks say.
You know how everyone says you can get herpes Herman tanning bed.
Now I heard the other day,
you can get aids from a tanning Beta,
there's somebody on your period and then you sit down on that blood and then
what?
And you have an open wound and your asshole a hemorrhoid and sucks it in like a
hemorrhoid.
Why would you have to kind of like until it inside your body,
you know,
like with blood,
blood doesn't like just go into your system.
You know what I mean?
Like it has to be stuck in there or squished together like Indian style and you
know,
is that,
does that work though?
I'm wondering if,
I'm wondering if you're war
[inaudible] 28 days later where if you bleed on Vibe,
they fucking turn into aids,
monkeys,
Zombie or whatever the fuck.
I think it's hard.
It's gotta be hard to get aids and it seems to be harder to get,
there has to be a lot of depression.
Well,
it's so crazy.
See that,
you know,
it came out and I remember what it came out.
That was the,
like the early 1980s there wasn't a big,
big public story.
And I'm,
I remember thinking,
oh my God,
like this is so crazy.
Eventually everyone's going to fuck everyone and give everyone
aids.
Right.
It's like you can't stop people from fucking,
and if there's some disease that kills people when you fuck it's were gone or
it's the end as we knew it.
Yeah,
no,
that sounded good.
And then all of a sudden it didn't happen that way.
You know,
like Magic Johnson was the first one that freaked everybody out.
I remember I was driving,
I was in revere.
Okay.
I was leaving the gym,
I was in my car with my girlfriend and we were listening to the radio and they
were talking about how magic Johnson was like,
make it some sort of a press conference to announce it.
He's,
he's got aids that he's HIV positive.
We were like,
Holy Shit,
Magic Johnson's going to die.
Whoa.
That was like,
that was reality.
I thought everyone's going to be dead.
We're going to be fucked because now obviously men are getting it from women and
women and getting it from men and men are getting it from men.
It's just fucking,
it's just a fuck sandwich out there.
Skeeto AIDS,
the AIDS mosquitoes.
Magic Johnson got to remember the fucking dope has aids.
It makes me look better.
Yeah,
he looks great.
He's not even aging is AIDS is causing him to not age fountain of Youth.
It's really,
he's like plump and like looks vitals,
killing it.
Healthy fucking strong skin.
There was that one person that was the first person.
That guy,
he's not sagging and everything.
He's not turning a no person.
He looks like a elastic.
He looks a lot and weird shit with it's dude.
He's got
here dope.
Did you hit that first guy that just got a cured yet?
Yeah,
that's what,
stem cells.
Yeah.
Fucking time.
Well,
you know there's a whole school of thought that,
that it doesn't,
the HIV and AIDS aren't real.
I don't understand it and I'm not even going to get into it,
but it's,
there's a guy named doctor Peter Duesberg and he's a biologist out of the
University of California Berkeley and he says there's no connection between HIV
and aids.
He said that aids would,
AIDS is when people are jacked.
He says a bunch of things you said it could be drug use and a lot of people it
is,
it's like a lot of it.
It's crystal meth and poppers and Emile nitrate and you know,
and they said it's a lot of other undiagnosed things and what it is just
crushing your t cell count and what his,
what he says is that the reason why people test positive for HIV is that HIV is
a very weak virus and it can only exist in the system of someone who's already
been compromised.
So it's instead of,
you know,
that HIV causes AIDS,
what he says is a symptom of the fact your systems is checked.
Right.
And the gay community like that.
They do a lot of crystal meth and poppers insurance too.
So I've heard,
so I've heard as well.
I don't,
you know,
I don't pretend that that makes sense though.
That doesn't make any sense that these scientists wouldn't have figured out that
HIV doesn't cause [inaudible] huge.
But do you really think that there'll be that kind of a cover up,
like in that massive escape [inaudible] where every scientist,
that kind of studies it goes all Yang.
Yang,
Yang connected.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
I don't think so.
That's a big,
yeah.
I just bet it's a complicated motherfucking virus all I just got super lucky.
I'll get that shit.
It's like a tasty low.
I don't got it yet.
Okay.
I know.
Got
it yet.
I'll get it tonight mother fucker too.
How about people that go looking for it,
man.
How about bug Chase's?
Oh God.
That's a scary thing,
man.
People that are on purpose getting HIV there on purpose,
Linton dude,
shoot loads into them.
They need to do that.
Is there a documentary on that?
I bet that would be an interesting documentary.
Like,
yeah,
you should do.
You should do for me.
That should be your next project with his pants now that the Austin videos out
and everybody,
if you go to my youtube page,
it's Joe Rogan,
d o.
T.
N.
E t is my youtube page and um,
there's a new video.
It's good times in Austin or something like that,
but Brian just just completed and it's a fucking masterpiece and things
spectacular.
A Little Austin.
Yeah,
a little Austin and it's got the Joey Diaz incident show,
the Alex Jones show,
which was the greatest thing I've ever seen on my time here on earth.
It was fuck Ufo is landing.
Fuck all that.
I mean,
do you have folks are going to be that funny.
That was better than anything I've ever seen.
I never seen a movie that made me laugh that hard,
man.
I've never seen anything that made me laugh that hard that I've never laughed
harder in my life.
One time I can't close Brian Cowen,
we were all stoned in a hotel room with Brian Count was doing his Jujitsu gay
rapist bit.
He does this Portuguese accent,
like this heavy Brazilian accent when we talks about,
you know,
like taking guys down a mountain there and then raping you
dear.
That sounds like Brian can paper.
He's hilarious.
One of the funniest guys can I can already visualize.
Yeah,
it's brilliant.
The bid is brilliant and was those,
those are close.
Those were close,
but I think Joey Diaz is going to take the cake because that was on on the radio
in front of probably a million listeners.
People watching it on the Internet from now until you know,
who knows when the videos were everywhere and it was God damn hilarious and it
was live.
He just totally hijacked that dude show.
Todd tracked it.
But my favorite part about it is like the stories hilarious on its own,
but then in that context of hijacking the live show and telling it angrily made
it like another level of fun dude.
But sorry,
lit up.
Just cue up his rant on the Alex Jones show to queue up that part and play it
for people.
Yeah.
Well you know what's crazy about the whole video two is it starts off with you
saying the word retard on the radio and how they had the sensor that you know,
and then it goes to the extreme of Joey Diaz,
saint fucking fat one.
I told you after I stopped saying though,
so that was going to stop saying faggot.
A guy emailed me and asked me to stop saying cock sucker as well,
and I'm like,
okay,
we're getting crazy.
Yeah.
Like we're getting crazy.
You can't say retard.
Look,
retarded is been a way that we describe people that are idiots forever and the,
it's not,
it's not offensive.
You know what's offensive?
It's offensive that you think that some sort of a,
a word is going to make any sort of a difference.
That's what's offensive.
It's,
it's,
that's,
that's ridiculous.
Look,
if I'm shitting on little kids that have down syndrome children,
you know,
that's,
that's cruel and horrible.
That's not a nice thing to do,
but it's not what we're talking about.
We're talking about someone being a retard.
You know what the fuck we're saying?
Yeah,
no,
people are fucking stupid.
What are you supposed to say?
Yes.
We'll say idiot and idiots.
Okay.
Yeah,
because I mean,
you could dissect every fucking where you know retarder originally was the desk,
the,
I think the medical designation for it was mongoloid idiot.
That was like the way they used to describe them.
So,
I mean that was like,
that was like the real nomenclature,
you know?
So retarded sounds way better than mongoloid it is.
Yeah.
Could you imagine what the fuck man.
Mongoloid is a funny word.
I think the whole stand thing too though.
The major things weird cause you grew up calling a midget.
Yeah.
No,
it's a little people.
Yeah,
that shits crazy.
That's why I call midgets retard.
Retard
targeted
and I caught midgets.
Faggots.
Target people.
I just switch it up.
That's the move,
man.
That's all I got.
Move.
All right.
Here's the Joey Diaz audio
[inaudible].
This is the Alex Jones studio.
Oh,
this is just the part that you described me before.
It goes right into it.
It's cooler this way.
The master of what's Cooler,
dude,
Joey Diaz.
Churchly Joe had,
I'm going to skip this last network right here,
right?
We're going skip the break.
I saw a humbling thing.
I said answer the funniest thing I ever saw my father life.
Hey,
good to see you as a little.
We always a pleasure.
Thanks for the delays on in there.
You're talking about smuggling.
We understand from the air force.
I had this Baggie and I belonged on my left side.
[inaudible] I know
this is real.
So this is not a control.
This is nice little ass design on it.
This whole bumping joints out of as worse.
Hold on.
He is worse than any problems.
Much worse told I love him,
but don't bring this monster out here.
It's like,
it's like a Flintstone.
So your viewers know the people in the line.
We're looking for.
The truth on this show is about the truth.
I got once I got that and I had baggy clothes on Delta,
they sound speakers,
rep baggy clothes on the indoor ones right now.
We said we're gonna put you,
if you x ray machine,
I'll stand in this wet and bullets with this baggy on the my fucking all that
salt off left us bigger on the regular cause I'm a ride.
He stopped like cancer for colleagues,
you know,
the opposite hand and somebody saw him stand up,
my legs open.
You're like Rodney Dangerfield,
come stop by.
You're talking about
not basic my balls.
I'm sweating now.
I lost it again.
Was that it shook my hand.
I'm like,
Mike,
Taxpayers are hard at Wharton.
Don't know.
I know I Joseph,
go fuck yourself.
You can't hold on one second.
Joey Diaz,
Facebook.
Check yourself before you wreck yourself.
Big Dixie Das.
[inaudible]
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Big Ticks in your ass and bad for your health.
Check yourself before you wreck yourself.
You know it's funny,
I was going to edit the song,
the ice teas or ice cube's song that that's from,
but that song is actually pretty stupid.
Like it's not a good,
coolest song to listen to you.
Maybe we good for that one quote,
but that quote,
that's funny cause I remember that song being great because of that line.
But then I listened to him.
I'm like,
Eh,
what?
Check Yourself Prereq yourself.
It's like chick,
you still,
people you make
for your health.
I come like this stove ideas took it to another level,
right?
Yeah.
He brought that up.
Used to find this guy ever.
There's no one.
I've never met anybody in my entire life.
That's funny.
Then Joey Diaz?
No one,
dude,
I just remember that I did a music video with Sandler like 10 years ago.
And Joey don't you,
we used his ball sack in the video.
It's a song about shaving your pubic hair.
No,
no.
And there's a clip of joy's balls bouncing up and down that online.
Yeah,
it's called,
um,
fuck.
I Trim my bushes.
I'm sure my,
my,
I can't remember him.
So Brandon trimmed my Bush or some shit,
whatever.
Does anybody ever say that at work?
I had to film that fat man on the toilet series,
which was Joey d is fat in the naked on a toilet.
And He,
the whole idea was that it was going to be made for cell phones where we filmed
him on the toilet,
giving advice,
like traffic,
horse scope,
whether news and stuff like that.
And then I had to be in this little,
uh,
bathroom with like every video recorder by myself.
I was a hot La Day and it was just him fucking naked and he would stamp,
you're like,
ah,
it's just balls hanging everywhere.
And it was like the humid in the bathroom.
You would just start ranting about shit,
there's nothing written.
Right,
right.
And I remember it was that this in this pool house of a friend of one of the
guys that work on fear factor or something like that.
David Herwoods.
Yeah.
And like,
like his goes,
oh no,
no,
I don't think man,
I don't think he was the director of or something like that.
Yeah.
And there's,
the wife came in and was like,
I brought you guys lemonade.
I'm like,
this is fucking creepy.
This is like my,
one of my first years out in La and I'm like,
I'm doing porn.
This is how I start doing corn.
Right.
Joey take a shit.
Uh,
no,
he just sat there the whole time and then I started giving him like Joey Diaz
doesn't,
he doesn't fit on toilets correctly.
Yeah.
So he leaves these,
these survivors that have like crashed this ship and
then
crawling up on the beach.
The best fucking change.
Right.
But Joey sheds there,
he leaves him a bathroom all the time.
Especially like in the humidity that makes me feel climbing up and trying to
escape like crabs in a bucket.
They're not totally in the water like half submerged.
The mirror was fogged and I wrote,
I love you on it and stuff like that because it was so humid from his balls in
there and the greatest parts,
the greatest party he'd stood up in,
his balls were hanging at least 12 inches or something like that and I kept on
throwing that toilet paper roll is trying to hit it like a carnival and at the
very end I fucking hit it.
Oh my God.
It's in the video.
It's called Jody is fat man on a toilet or something like that to his line,
his balls,
they literally look like rocks and an old lady's videos.
They're ridiculous.
I never seen balls so big in my life.
It doesn't even make sense.
Yeah.
Which brings me up to a very important point,
chuck this up my next door.
Well,
I don't want to say that.
Some people that I know.
Nice,
Nice.
See the people that I know,
they're very nice people.
This
gay couple.
They,
um,
they had a kid and they,
they impregnated a woman with their loads and the way they did it was they put
their loads together and then they mixed it up.
No,
a squirt it in fall.
It was like I'm on or off.
And it was just like,
hopefully it's my,
it's fucking shit.
What's fascinating about that?
I mean it's fascinating
about that cause it's kind of weird.
Like they,
they really did,
they didn't just adopt a baby.
They created a baby with their own genetics.
Like they have a couple somehow or another.
I mean they'll figure out eventually whose baby it really is,
you know,
especially if they get in fights or something like that.
But the,
the idea is that somehow or another,
you know,
you're going to figure out,
you're going to get this,
these loads in there and it's gonna,
you know,
they're going to just have a race,
but they're not going to have a race.
They're going to murder each other.
Right.
Like a big percentage of the loads that you shoot are just murderous sperm
killers.
They're all they want to do is go kill other sperm.
They're sent out there to make sure that the sperm that's already in the cooler,
it doesn't get to the eggs.
And so they attack and they go smash it.
And the,
the more promiscuous the women are,
the more your body produces more of these crazy killer sperm.
That's why ball size is directly proportional to female slots in the community.
So like that's why gorillas have little balls.
Gorillas have little balls because female gorillas are chill.
They're not horse chimpanzees have giant balls because female chimps are fucking
whores.
They're whores.
They just want chimp,
Dick all over town Kerry.
And so these chimps have to force those killer loads in there so that their
genetics can move on to attack the loads.
So these guys in creating this baby,
they really launched this sperm fucking genocide campaign where they just
attacked each other in the dish.
Oh my God.
You know,
there's no harmony in the in that
there is no harmony in that.
And then we should do,
they should have like a like see through flashlights and then let's all fuck it.
And there'll be like an ant farm and what?
Just watched all this shit go down on the fighter,
the sperm fight.
Wow.
I wonder if you could,
that's so true,
right?
I don't know.
Wow.
If you were like,
you know,
like you had a box and you can only,
well you don't want to receive each other while you're shooting loads,
but if you,
you had like something like the to room Bluetooth,
like video,
maybe it's like yours,
a hole in the wall and the fleshlight is attached to the hole in the wall,
right?
And you're in one room fucking it and your friends and another room.
Fuck it.
And it falls into the center and that's the catch tray.
And then it mixes them all together under some super powerful microscope.
And we would watch sperm wars,
sperm wars.
If you imagine that it would be like,
let's,
let's just pitch it.
Let's pitch it,
dude.
Let's at least set up a meeting and just pitch it around how to see the look on
people's faces and you,
and it's like,
you want me to put our names on it?
So we just say we're totally committed to the show.
Like this is our,
this is our fucking dreams for Morris.
It's actually a good idea for a show.
You could have a show where you took celebrities and you,
you,
you shot their loads.
You know,
they,
they do this,
you know,
they don't have to actually do it.
You know,
you just pretend they're doing it and then you animate what's going on with
their loads.
Yeah,
that'd be sweet to,
you know,
like Dwayne the Rock Johnson versus Brock Lesnar.
Get their loads together and battle it out.
You could have like fucking Daniel Day Lewis versus fucking Jeremy Irons.
Ooh,
I liked that one.
Classy sperm fight.
A classy,
a fucking method.
Sperm English accent.
Sperms,
sperms.
So white gloves at dual,
perhaps I duo and duo.
It's amazing how much distinction that accent carries.
How much more you take someone's opinion.
Seriously.
Yeah.
They just sound so much smarter like that.
A,
I love that show.
Top gear.
You ever watched that show?
No.
What is it to UK show about?
About cars mostly.
So they just,
they,
they go on these little trips and shit and they drive these crazy Ferrari's and
shit all over the place and they have like little games that they play on little
contests they do with each other and you're like,
who can get,
like,
they'll one,
one guy will be in a,
in a Ferrari,
the other guys have to catch a plane and you know,
and then a train and he has a straight John Ferrara you'd want to see who makes
it their first,
you know,
so they do a bunch of shit like that.
But Jeremy Clarkson,
who's the main host guy and both,
all three of the guys that are hosts,
they're all English and because their English,
because they have that English accent,
when they make fun of something,
it seems so preposterous.
Like they seemed so correct.
Right.
Very,
very influential on,
on,
on Americans for some reason.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
All Americans aren't thrilled with that accent is a killer.
Australian is like,
you're a little dirty,
you know,
if you've got that Australian thing,
we'll hear you like to party a little crazier.
You know you've got the like to party English.
The Marines.
Yeah.
It's like they're really close,
but they're more like more like potty.
We had a polity,
Mike.
Yeah.
Is that good?
No.
Why is that?
I bowl.
Yeah,
they're crazier.
The Australians a little wilder.
The English are thought of as more distinctive trait that Ohio and mate don't be
fucking pussy.
Excellent.
That was,
and there was a combination.
I think that was Welsh.
Yeah.
It was like Aztec meets fucking the craziest I've ever met is a Dublin,
no,
not Dublin.
Belfast,
Northern Ireland.
Jesus.
I've never,
never talked to anybody with an accident like that before.
Their accent is almost impenetrable when they're talking to you.
It's almost like you'd like right in front of a dude he speaking English and you
don't have a fucking clue what he's saying.
What was that accident that movie's snatch Morelos dudes couldn't make out.
They were Gypsies,
right?
Doesn't Z.
Yeah.
Brad Pitt at the crazy fucking ex.
Hikeys that's what that's right.
Yeah.
Pikeys
cause that's what it sounded like,
man.
That's what it's like in Belfast.
Belfast is nuts.
Belfast never been to a place more depressing.
You know.
And then people in Vail Pass Paradise,
they get,
they get mad when I say this,
I've said this a few times,
you know,
and people from Belfast to like fuck you,
this is the output.
Could bill festers also,
it's raining every day,
dude.
It's raining everyday.
Everything's gray.
If you take a color picture of something,
you have no idea it's color cause it's fucking great.
Looks like old times.
God Damn Black and white.
Why would they,
even if if we lived in Belfast,
we would never even need to invent color cameras cause you wouldn't use them.
Everything's fucking gray by the way.
I hate it when people are from a place and he like,
they can't even shit on their own.
Like I'm from Minnesota,
there's bad parts that there's bad things about it.
I can fucking admit that I hated when people are like,
I'm from here dude.
No it's my book and grew up,
it's like silly.
Oh fuck.
People get attached to different,
they get attached to their patch of dirt.
You know,
like they get attached to their,
their challenge,
their spot.
This is our fucking area,
man.
What's the deal with Gypsies?
Do they even exist?
Is that even a race?
Absolutely.
So when you say like those Gypsies in that going through my trash,
that's like,
is that like saying that those are really Gypsies or I'm calling him Gypsies for
a reason.
There are a whole lot of them here in America or in Europe though.
There's a lot of Gypsies.
Yeah.
I mean it's just people traveling around.
They seem like they hide good or something.
Well,
they know a lot about Werewolf's.
If you're ever been a werewolf movie,
shitload about wearables.
Gypsies are always the ones,
man.
The latest one was Benito del Toro.
Very Gypsy based,
heavy in the Gypsy content.
Did I love Gypsies?
You ever had sex with a gypsy?
Well,
no.
I have a gypsy fleshlight though.
Yeah.
What's the difference?
That's kind of fucking Bandana on and fucking drink hits and shit and fucking
like fucking whispers and shit and like sides and the bracelets.
Shit.
Dirty dirty ankle bracelets.
Every girl who has anchor bolts,
it's wants Dick.
That's a fact.
If you're walking around with ankle bracelets on,
you want some Dick or a toe ring or a toe.
Right?
That's just a fucking Dick dive started,
bitch.
She says,
goddamn cocked magnet.
I used to wear two hats on fucking Dick Diving board and yeah man,
you trying to look sparkly and shiny.
Your ankles
and your feet.
What are you saying?
Yeah,
look at your legs.
That's what you want.
Yeah.
How much difference is that then?
Like I'll watch though.
You know people that are obsessed with watches for guys like jewelry,
it's no different,
but every guy wants pussy.
See or every guy wants sex every 100%.
Most women don't want sex from you.
That's what the deal is.
That's the difference.
So in a guy doing it makes sense.
He's trying to attract someone who's like,
look at the shiny.
Yeah,
you are so shiny with your shiny,
I would just start wearing sequence shirts then.
It's not that you gotta be careful.
We didn't.
Yeah,
cause it's gonna attract the wrong.
It's too much shine.
Amex guys go,
I want that.
If it were really just,
if the shiny was the only key people would have like diamond top hats and shit
and fucking life,
I would have a fucking diamond turtleneck and just be walking around and,
and Keynes sequence.
No Sir.
Dumb or the um,
environment,
you know,
the more,
more diamonds who will use.
Right.
You know,
your pretend time by the way is fucking hilarious.
Have you seen his new show and kind of having that I'm guilty of not seeing very
good.
Nick Swardson is attached.
It has my unequivocal bowl seal of approval.
I love with standing.
I'm sure I would love it.
And so filthy and fucked up.
Can you believe it?
Love it as I hate it.
I have people come up to the fucking debt.
I means you're doing the total correct thing.
Yeah.
That's what I think.
I love the cat in the wheelchair.
That's one of my favorite,
favorite critic goes your show.
I have a sketch show up for people who don't know it's already done.
But um,
for uh,
at a Kritikos uh,
yeah,
I watched Nick Swardson show.
It's just the same old shit we've seen before.
Literally my shows that cat in a wheelchair that does cocaine.
Yeah.
What a broken record.
That theme is a cat in a fucking wheelchair that this coke.
Yeah.
God been there,
done that.
Have A,
I have a huge problem with really,
really mediocre people that are criticizing other people.
Really mediocre writers really mean,
Oh my God.
This day and age is fucking crazy because anybody can be a credit.
Yeah.
All you have to do and there's a website can retarded.
And if your snarky enough and if you're shitty enough about people,
you know you can get really popular.
A lot of these websites,
they just keep at it every day and they're shitty and Douchey to people and they
get a lot of hits,
you know?
And so that everybody starts thinking,
well that's all I need to do to be a critic.
I just need to be a Douche bag.
And so,
you know,
critics equal,
you just try to find out a way to shit on things,
you know,
and your,
your actual assessment of what you like or don't like it.
There's no real substance to any event cause you're a fucking moron.
If you had anything to contribute,
you wouldn't be a goddamn critic in the first place.
Right.
I mean,
yeah.
What the hell would want to be a critic of your creative person?
I mean,
there's one thing to be a appreciator of,
of art and that appreciation leads you to be a critical,
like I think like,
like Roger Ebert,
I think that got truly appreciates the art of filmmaking,
I think.
Absolutely.
There's critics like that that are artists.
They're like these,
he actually appreciates what he's talking about.
It's like a really important,
meaningful thing to him.
But then on the flip side,
I don't,
I get annoyed by critics who like,
we'll see movies that I do and you know,
Roger Ebert in particular,
but the guys who are like high Falutin critics and they'd be like,
yeah,
I saw benchwarmers this is garbage.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
that's not fucking for you.
You know what I mean?
Like if you're a big critic,
like Joan Review a movie that you're obviously going to find flaws in the plot
of like,
what the fuck?
You know,
people do silly movie,
you're going to a fucking hot
dog store and they're looking for some insane seven course French dinner.
You're not going to get it stupid.
That's a hot dog.
And hot dogs are cool too.
You're not going to get it good.
You know,
people don't understand,
man.
Yeah,
you got to fucking Taco Bell.
You're not going to get fucking Salmon Sashimi.
It is what it is.
Smoke a joint,
go sick,
giggle Dun Dun,
Dun,
Dun.
That's it.
That's all you gotta do.
And it's mostly for kids.
So what the fuck's your problem,
man?
It's about little league baseball.
You fucking piece of shit.
You mother fucker.
You bought the fucker.
Yeah.
Now I've got this theory about critics though
and about all this negativity on the Internet,
on the Internet.
I think in some ways it's good because I think it's like a,
it's like getting a little bit of snake venom all the time.
You know,
you get a little bit here,
a little bit there and eventually become immune to snake venom.
Whereas a lot of people who've never experienced anything like criticism on the
Internet from anonymous people just being completely shitty about yet it's
gnarly,
gnarly.
And for a lot of people that are experiencing it,
it's like you've got a jolt to their system.
Like I've seen,
I've met people that have gone through,
you know,
they've got like some internet fame or had some things happen to them and you
can tell like when people have been shit on,
you can tell when like a lot of people have attacked them with hate mail.
It's just like jolts their personality.
So a little bit here and there from Douche bags here and there.
You just gotta realize eventually you come to this sort of a recognition that
the reason why the communicating like that is not really necessarily because
they didn't really,
they responded that way to your product.
A lot of the reason why they're communicating that way is because they're a
mess.
They're a mess as a human being than not that creative and not that special.
They're angry all the time.
Their relationships probably don't work out very well.
They're filled with anxious.
They don't know how to become great.
They want something more than what they are.
They want to be treated as special even though they don't want to actually do
the work to become special there.
Right.
Well it's like with Stan,
it's inevitable that you're going to get fucking haters.
Yeah.
Cause I could stand up.
It's like you can't have a great show every,
you know,
like that's when I had started doing stand up and you get to that thing where
it's like you're going to fucking bomb eventually half like you have to.
So I always tell people who want to do stand up.
Like you know it's gonna,
it's fucking hardest as shit and you're going to fucking,
it's not fun.
Yeah.
Hardest part.
The hardest part is not doing well.
There's this like when you feel Joey Diaz says it best,
he said stand up is,
it's the hardest,
easiest thing you love to do.
Right.
The hottest,
easiest thing.
Cause when it's easy,
it's easy.
When it's hot,
it's hard to know.
When he's like Yoga and you get like visit off,
it's so fucking awful.
It's brutal.
I've had that happen.
I've eaten shit several times in my life where I was like,
I felt like,
like almost like as low as a dog.
It's like
awful dude.
I'm in.
The first time I got booed off stage I was like shell shocked.
Like my hands were shaking.
Like I didn't go.
I didn't go on stage for like a week.
Dude in New York.
It was fucking awful.
Yeah,
it can get you.
it's scary.
And then we'll let you know once you,
you know,
it's a weird thing then that stand up like that negative standup is so painful.
It's very like if you want it to look at it like as a psychological study,
it's a really intriguing topic because what's going on is you are requiring so
much attention.
You were asking for so much energy if so much focus on you that you're actually
standing on a stage with an amplified voice and a spotlight on you and this is
like a big brash step to take.
And if you're eating enough there and people paid money to see you talk and the
the anger swells up inside them,
they want you to know like this is not entertaining.
Yeah,
that's fuck you fun.
You feel those few are failing at your job.
You were given a job and you're making every bring up shit and you're doing the
fucking opposite and now we're angry and we're fucking turning into a mob.
Yeah,
and we're going to fucking fist you when you're exact opposite man.
If you ever seen a guy say something like super offensive,
like sometimes comics will say something and what they're just trying to do is
just trying to come up with something funny and it,
a lot of it comes out before you've really thought about it and a lot of comics
will like,
you know,
they'll,
they'll try to be like super controversial and they'll say like insulting shit,
but just it just like the Kramer nigger thing like that.
Like he didn't know what he was doing.
He fucked up.
He's an idiot obviously,
but it's like what it was he doing?
He was just taking chances.
He was just seeing what's in the cylinders,
pulling triggers.
He didn't know what he does what these yet bullets and blanks.
What do I got here?
I got a rocket.
I'm just fucking panicking and dying up here.
And people were yelling at them that you suck you a funny look.
We have a nigger.
He just,
yeah.
Oh.
And then he's committed to it.
He's like,
I'm just going to go with this.
This is my new sketch.
That,
by the way,
for people who want to do stand up,
don't push that panic button.
That's the wrong button on the Kramer.
Pushed was one on one run state.
Every other button is literally take a shit on the stage,
pull your pants down,
take a shit,
throw it at someone like a fucking monkey but did not do not drop a fucking and
Butler on sewage.
Oh yeah,
you gotta be real careful with that one.
God.
And it was funny cause then Kramer tried to do it with like Kramer mannerisms or
it was just like,
I dunno Kramer not where he was doing a lot of weird shit on stage.
It was really strange.
He was coming to the comedy store a lot and uh,
it was real weird because he didn't really like talk to anybody,
you know,
who's just kind of odd,
you know how he's hanging out and he would do like these weird like pratfalls
and sketches and stuff on stage.
It was very strange.
I got into a fight with him.
Did you really?
Yeah.
About what I want to Improv one night.
And I walked in the showroom and it was like a pretty full crowd and he was on
stage.
This is a week
before fucking n extravaganza happened.
So he's onstage and he's melting dot melting the fuck.
Talking about the war.
There was no jokes and he just was like getting like dark.
And the crowd was like super uncomfortable.
And so I tried to show her manager and I go give him the fucking light.
And he goes,
no,
it's,
I can't,
it's Michael Richards.
I go,
give them the fucking light.
And he goes,
no.
And I go,
I'm all give him the fucking light.
So I started fucking flashing the light.
Wow.
And he looks at the light and he looks over at the booth.
He looks at me and I would just kept flashing the light and he fucking got off.
And we,
uh,
after,
after a minute,
and I grabbed the mic and I go,
bring me on after him,
I wasn't going to go on,
but I go bring me on.
And they were like,
oh,
okay.
So then they brought me right up and he's passing me as he's walking on stage.
He's like,
who the fuck?
Give me the line.
I go,
I gave you the fucking light.
And I went on stage and did a fucking half hour.
So the crowd had a fucking good show,
you know what I mean?
Like,
and he was yelling in the back of the room is fucking livid.
And I just,
and I,
and I fucking go.
I'm sorry that you guys had to fucking see that I fucking sense for Michael
results.
I go,
you know,
it didn't fucking pay to,
this dude was holding them fucking prisoner.
No jokes was yelling at them like,
be rating this crowd.
I was like,
whoa,
fuck you bro.
And then a week later he got fucking that.
That was that.
The whole end thing.
Right.
Thank you.
Is gacked up on something?
I do.
I saw him that night that you went to.
I Dunno dude.
He was from,
he thought he was ganged up on something.
He,
you saw him at the comedy store,
right?
What happened is he went to the comedy store first and before you went to the
laugh factory and he brought this a friend of his and they were just acting
really fucked up.
And then he went on stage,
ate shit.
And I was like telling you,
I called you,
I said something like,
dude,
uh,
Kramer,
Michael Richards was just here,
man,
you should see he was fucked up and he,
you know,
all this other crap.
Yeah.
You said he had a meltdown and then Brent earns,
drove from the laugh factory comedy store need to told the whole story to
everybody.
Wow.
And everybody was like,
well,
we thought that was going to be the end of it though.
We had no idea that was gonna be a video of it.
He goes,
dude,
you know,
Brenner and schools into this fucking whole story about him.
Like he's,
she's on stage drop at the end bomb.
I'm freaking the fuck out.
He's calling these guys not just dropping the Emma calling these guys calling.
Look,
here's there are niggers.
Yeah.
Pointing.
It was like,
whoa.
And we were all,
we were all super big too.
So it seems so surreal.
It didn't seem real at all.
When you hear a story like that,
you're like what?
Kramer said this Kramer Southern Way Uhf is on my favorite movies.
Yeah,
me too.
Me Too.
I'm sorry I can't give a shout out to UHF.
It's weird when those guys go from being on a sitcom to not being on a sitcom
anymore and then trying to do standup,
which is you go from this world where the fake producer laugh.
Like when you're doing a sitcom and you do like run throughs,
everyone laughs at their own jokes.
So you're like,
Mike,
what kind of a can is that?
It's like everyone laughs in the background because the producers want the
network to think that what you're saying is so hilarious.
I gets
so bad sometimes like when you're doing reshoots that it's,
it's actually distracting.
Like when you have to reshoot a scene where something didn't work right.
And so when they,
the shoot a scene,
like they don't have an audience sometimes will,
we would do it like on news radio until like two o'clock in the morning.
And so you would do it and then you'd hear
is gross,
fake laugh from the producers or from the right.
Right.
So they go from that world where like everybody laughs at everything you say.
Would you like another Bagel?
This done magic land.
Yeah.
He's just living in this fucking world where he's,
uh,
he's a goddamn king.
You know,
they show up on the set and there's a parking spot with your name on it and
everybody stumbles over themselves to get you coffee.
And would you like a magazine?
What can we do for you,
sir?
I just,
it's so disrespectful,
you know?
Oh,
sue told me.
Cause it's like I'm just as a psychological study that,
yeah,
no,
I hear you.
I just,
I hate it when people do that shit where it's like,
I mean,
even like myself,
I took a year off from standup because I didn't have a new act that,
you know,
that I was,
I,
that I really was happy with.
I'm working on it right now,
but it's like I am a,
but I not set up for 16 years.
I,
you know,
and I was like,
I'm going to take time off because I'm not ready.
So from other fuckers that go onstage and be like,
yeah,
I'm fucking famous,
I'll just go up and just stand there and fucking try to wing it.
It's like fuck you dude.
You're totally,
totally,
completely agree with you.
And totally side with your,
you know,
decision to like the pump,
the crown off and everything.
But what I'm looking at as a crazy person,
I don't think it's as simple as like,
here's a guy who,
you know,
he just,
you're saying like lack of attention.
Like they need that fill that void of like,
yeah,
he's,
he's broken.
I think there's a pathology there.
I think there's quite a few actors.
There's a pathology and the,
the,
the solution to this pathology is attention.
Massive,
massive doses of attention.
You know,
I think there's a lot of people that are famous are crazy and the re the way to
become,
you know,
recognized the way to get what they're looking for is just to be extraordinary.
It's something,
you know,
so look,
I am special.
So whether it's acting,
whether it's singing or their,
whatever it is,
they start out with a pathology,
they start out with,
they've got to fucking psychological disorder.
There's some wiring.
It's fucked up.
I think that's a huge percentage of people that are famous.
Right.
I agree.
And I mean that's what brings on the drug.
And so,
you know,
which I don't partake in.
Never.
I've heard that it's very prominent in the community.
I've heard it too.
I find it events hear about that.
It's not necessarily,
I just smelled it before.
Yeah.
Which part that,
hey did,
did you,
uh,
do you have any time to do stand up right now?
Like you've been like,
it seems like you're in like four movies being made for different TV shows.
Like you're just being worked like crazy.
Are you crazy a man?
It was cool.
I knock on wood,
I'm very,
I was very,
yeah,
it was a great year.
I don't think you like disappeared for like six months.
It seemed like I did.
I shot two movies out of town and then,
uh,
but I took a while off stand up and I'm getting back into it.
But you know,
I was,
I could have toured and done more shows,
but I just,
I don't believe in paying,
having people paid to see the same act I just did on fucking TV.
What do you,
how do you,
um,
when you do that,
right?
Like everybody's got their own method.
I think Louis Ck is methods the most fascinating.
He does a new one every year.
I don't know how the fuck he does have some am maniac is insane.
We're so hard.
Just works really hard.
I was like,
Brian Regan Gaf again,
like those guys,
right.
So much.
I try to write a lot.
I'm ready for a new special now I have a no,
so it's,
for me,
it's like,
it's been almost two years since I filmed the last one.
I have enough material now for another one.
Oh,
that's great.
But it's a,
it's tricky,
man.
I'm scared.
I'm gonna release this.
I,
I know I'm going to release this and then I got to go on.
I'm mad writing spree for like four months cause you have like four months from
the time that you film something to the time it actually gets,
you know,
dumping in a ride.
I got to go crazy.
No,
I got shows to do bitch.
I got come and come up some new jokes.
I got to do some mushrooms.
That's the move man.
I need a new uh,
a new level.
Need to hit a new level.
Yeah.
I just zone out next level.
Shit.
Crazy shit while I'm driving.
That helps.
I never,
I never sit down and write it.
Drive with no,
uh,
no music on,
right?
Yeah.
I'll just fucking zone out and fucking take a crazy shit.
There's something about driving that's almost like meditative.
If you have your mind is fucking goes away.
Yeah.
There's like part of your brain and says,
okay,
we only need this amount to pay attention to where we're going.
We need this amount.
Look at all this free brain we got.
Yeah.
Well what do you want to do?
You want to think about shit.
Okay,
let's think about life.
Hey,
let's think about some with farting.
[inaudible] about a new thing about farting.
Because when you listen to the music,
you know,
which is great.
I love listening to music in my car,
but then you're not thinking as much.
Then you go get another 10% of your brain is occupied with that.
Right,
right.
Or more.
Yeah.
I have like a new half hour.
I'm pretty psyched,
but I need money.
I need a fucking another half hour.
So how do you don't sit down and write,
you know,
ever.
Right.
I never have really come up with it on the fly.
I come up with stuff on the fly or I'll just keep adding,
you know,
I'll go up on stage with a premise and then we'll work it out and then just find
more stuff in that premise.
You know,
your whole act in your head or do you have things written down?
Yes ma'am.
I always write it down.
I'll bring up a little piece of paper.
You always write it down before you go up on stage new stuff.
And I put it,
yeah.
But I only go on with new stuff.
I mean,
it's rare that you'll see me tell the same,
but what I'm saying is like,
do you,
do you have any,
do you have your stuff written out anywhere?
Like you have like,
here's my,
you know,
monkey bananas.
Nothing.
You record your shit and listen to it ever.
No,
you should really do that.
That's the best.
That's what I've heard.
I have an iPhone just poured,
listen to it on the way home makes a big difference,
man.
There's so many little taglines that I forgot about that.
That's funny is I forget nuances of fire trucks.
That's annoying,
man.
When you come up with the perfect tag,
it's like perfect.
Then you go with mother fucker.
I'm not recording this show.
It's also embarrassing,
like I don't know if that's ever happened to you when someone reminds you of
like a really good joke that you told one.
Yes,
and I'm like,
oh,
I forgot about that one.
They're like,
Oh,
I love that joke.
It's like,
yeah,
I'm real professional.
I can remember my own fucking jokes.
I'm like,
oh,
I did like that joke.
Yeah.
Thank you for reminding me of my own act.
Yeah,
well cause I'm a fucking idiot.
People will call out request sometimes it shows,
you know,
like,
at the end of the show I do like a question answer thing.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That's a cool idea.
It's fun.
So much fun.
You know?
And um,
when,
uh,
people will call out beds like two,
I,
Anna Nicole Smith,
I'm like,
I don't even know how to do it.
Right.
Yeah.
I don't know how it goes.
I know that if you don't know how it goes anymore,
I don't,
I know it was mine.
I know I wrote it.
I don't,
I remember how it goes.
That's to go listen to it a bunch of times and then practice it and shit.
Yeah.
That's the worst whenever I go home to Minnesota because I started there.
So I've done stand there for 16 years.
So people would call out jokes that I told and an open Mike 10,
12,
15 years ago,
like I do the fried chicken bet.
I'm like,
what?
I don't know.
That is,
does Minnesota have like a real,
um,
like community,
a standup comedy community gets sick,
find mine.
It's got like,
is that what's one of the bat?
Yeah.
Acme is one of the best comedy clubs in the country.
But yeah,
they've got a good scene there dude.
It's awesome.
You've got,
you've done stand up in Minneapolis.
Yeah.
You can once you came on stage.
Yeah,
yeah.
That came on Trump.
But my pants falling off.
It was awesome.
[inaudible] cafe.
That was fun man.
That was cool.
That was,
you know,
you're the only guy who's ever come on stage with me before ever.
Really.
You know?
No one's ever done that before.
Never.
That's a good video.
It was fun Joe Show Minneapolis.
So that was fun.
You killed it.
Great one.
But they're great crowds.
They were awesome.
Awesome dude.
I've been wanting to go back and do a acme cause I keep hearing how amazing acne
is.
Everybody says it's like one of the best comedy clothes.
Dude,
you fucking love it.
Everybody says that man,
there's only a few comedy clubs in the country that totally have it nailed.
You know,
like there's the comedy works in Denver and you know there's a few other ones.
They still do that fucking early show though.
I hate the early show.
I don't have to do it dude.
There's a three shows on Saturday.
I do now.
I can't do three shows anyway.
I don't fucking know.
I can't do that too is all I can.
If I did a third,
I'd just be greedy.
You know,
it'd be given a half ass show.
It's not the same.
You're exhausted to two hours of,
you know,
after that is over man.
The last column I did was the Chicago Improv.
You did three.
I did know I did Thursday to Friday to Saturday and one Sunday and I looked like
fucking Betty White
the fucking Sunday.
I partied
so hard I can't even do it at do.
It's so hard to go into a club because I went in early and went to like cubs
games and just got fucking twisted dude.
So I came in out of the gate.
It's just,
it's like so hard dude.
Cause people get fucking,
like my fans are fucking crazy.
Like,
I'll get two shots on stage anymore.
I cut all that stuff out.
Really just because the flood gates,
it just turns into it.
I can get dangerous.
Yeah.
I did it at Caroline's wants and it was a huge mistake.
Oh No.
At one time I was a minute in Minneapolis and I was like just on a bender and I
fucking grabbed the waitress.
I go,
Hey,
can I get a drink on stage?
She was like,
yeah,
what do you want?
I go,
can I get sick shots of Tequila all by the way,
all for me.
The crowd looks at me.
It's fucking horrified.
Like I thought people can be like,
Yay.
And they were just staring at me and then I just realized like I looked like
such an alcoholic.
So then I made the another great choice of going,
does anybody want to do these with me?
And just was like,
oh,
so wow.
Yeah,
but it was pretty funny.
I saw Joe Meltdown in Vegas.
How long is it?
21 shot.
Sorry.
It's grown in stature over the years.
I don't know how many.
It was lean.
At least 13 tequila.
We knows lease 30 it was all kinds of stuff.
I threw up into a garbage can.
I've started off stage.
I was so hammered on stage,
I couldn't remember jokes.
I couldn't talk.
It was ridiculous.
I get off stage and throw up into a garbage can and I remember not believing how
much liquid was coming out of my body.
Like this doesn't even make sense.
Like this is like what?
This is like a broken fire hydrants on it.
It was like a pie eating scene
and stand by me,
stand by me.
Cartoonish amount of liquid was horrible.
I have photos but they were lost.
Dude already landed one fucking girls as things I've seen.
He went to the show in Vegas and uh,
I was hanging out with them and somebody,
he was like,
Sam,
you have any Jack?
And someone threw a Luke warm fucking bottle of Jack on stage,
lukewarm already,
pours it into a fucking big glass,
takes a straw and sucks the whole thing down.
Oh,
it was probably,
it was,
what's not a pint or what the fuck is it?
Those are like flasks,
like glass,
fuck it,
whatever.
I'm not sure that that was real.
That might,
it wasn't a plant.
It was I,
cause I was like,
it's gotta be a plant.
No,
because he opened up the seal and everything was,
it was like a brand new bottle.
Wow.
Whoa.
And chugged it.
I almost did.
I almost threw up watching it.
That jacket's hard.
Luke warm.
How bad did that affect you when that Artie Lange thing went down when he tried
to commit suicide?
Oh,
it was terrible,
man.
I was really,
I mean,
yeah,
it was fucked up.
Do you connect yourself?
Like when you have friends that are comics and you know,
comics and they do they do things in the commit suicide and shit like that?
Like does that,
uh,
how,
how does that freak you out?
I get really,
really emotional,
really emotional.
Greg Giraldo was really,
really good friend.
Mitch Hedberg was a good friend.
I mean,
I was,
I cried for a long time when Mitch died.
It was fucking awful.
Dude.
I'll never forget that.
I just,
it was terrible.
And he was to me,
Greg,
unique talent.
Oh yeah.
But Greg,
I was devastated when Greg died.
I mean,
I've known,
I've known Greg,
he was one of the first comics I've ever,
I'm at.
So we were friends 15 years ago.
He's was my first friend in New York.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean I party hard,
you know what I mean?
But it's like,
you know,
those guys were on another level,
he'll guys,
the guys who will just grab pills,
you know,
I was at,
uh,
at the comedy store one night and a buddy of mine came to see me and he goes,
hey man,
you want an oxy?
I keep it.
Yeah.
I was like,
what are you giving me?
Heroin?
You're going to give me a heroin pill.
What the fuck,
dude?
You know,
what is going on?
That's it.
That's another level of partying.
That pillow.
Yeah.
Like there's another level.
I mean,
yeah,
I fucking drank and shit,
but it's like,
there's another,
a whole nother dimension.
But
some guys,
man,
you know,
it's like,
it's like what happened in Vegas like after like six shots,
like you're,
you're gone.
The guns Ville,
you know,
if you took something and then the take something that leads to more bad
judgment and then somebody offers you something else and you throw that in the
mix too.
And who else wants to join the party?
You know,
you're just,
you're already down.
I'm not thinking well land,
you know,
you're already intoxicated.
You're fucked up.
You're drunk,
you're high on something,
whatever it is,
cause it's causing you.
That's why I get so mad when people connect pot with any of those other drugs
because pot does the exact,
that sucked,
that connect.
It makes you super paranoid.
You don't start thinking your superman and you'll fucking take drugs.
Somebody gives you some pills.
Like what the fuck is that?
He could have by trying to poison me.
He might be working for the government and they,
you start thinking a million different retarded things.
You don't think you fucking give it to me on ticket.
What's the last thing you think?
Yeah.
I mean I've never took a hit of a joint and then been like,
we gotta get coke.
It's like nobody ever does.
Pod is the anti gateway truck.
It's the exact opposite.
It gets you paranoid and makes you humble and it makes you not want to do all
those other drugs cause you don't want to fucking die cause you want to hug your
mom because you forgot to tell your lover,
you know,
and you start thinking about your friends and man hours.
It should be just like more generous or something.
I need to be a nicer need to be a nicer person.
And then those are the messages of marijuana.
Marijuana is the,
the happy
oozes the fucking killer dude.
Yeah.
You could be totally a,
yeah,
but that's the blood in the toilet.
But booze is responsible for a lot of fun.
I love you can't,
you can't hate on boots.
I think it's like people will like on my Facebook and stuff like,
and people I know or like try to like intervene like I have a problem.
You know when people are like,
Hey,
you're fucking alcoholic,
you're destroying yourself.
It's like,
first of all,
I drank.
I drank every weekend.
Yes I do.
I'm not the only one at the bars.
It's not fucking an empty room that I'm drinking it.
You know what I mean?
Like people don't understand like you can go out and have fun.
I don't drink because I'm sad.
I like,
I love drinking,
I love going out.
It's like the best to be like,
I fucking have a blast.
So like people don't understand that though.
They like if I had to be sober for a year,
I could,
you know what I mean?
It's not like I would freaking figures just the bottom
line.
You are not going to live forever.
Even if you eat fucking sprouts,
literally,
you're not gonna live forever.
It's not going to happen.
And boost is fun.
You know the,
if you're,
if you're partying with a bunch of friends and you do a few shots and everybody
gets lifted and they all start laughing,
you're fucking asses off as long as you,
with good drunks.
Honestly,
you're not with people that become assholes when they get drunk,
which by the way,
there's a new study that just came out today where they linked a gene that was
my elbow.
Oh Wow.
She's,
nope,
I didn't even flinch.
I'm a hard man.
Okay.
Anyway,
there's a study that came out that said that there's a gene that they've
isolated that causes violent behavior in some men when they drink,
like it's actually a gene.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Like they think that like,
you know,
dude,
we have friends,
you know,
we know people that drink and just become a totally different person.
Now they're saying like there's a reason for this.
Like the,
there's like certain people have certain genetics links and make them respond a
certain way.
Yeah,
I can see that.
Yeah.
So in that sense,
booze is not for everybody,
but nothing's for everybody,
right?
Yeah.
Nothing is for everybody.
Some people can't eat peanuts.
Some people can paint.
It's some people,
some people are allergic to wheat.
Just stick to wine.
Some people can't look at fucking a dolphin.
[inaudible] know what happened.
I don't know if that happens,
but that might,
I think they fucking shit their pants or something.
They shit their pants.
Yeah.
I knew this girl that you can't,
she can't see somebody put cotton in their mouth.
I can't touch the cotton.
You can.
I get really uncomfortable.
You have no cotton balls.
Cotton balls.
Like just straight cotton.
Like it gives me like,
Whoa,
what is that about?
I don't know.
Which just makes you uncomfortable.
Really?
Yeah.
Whoa.
So that way I can fucking do heroin.
So are you scared of Q tips though?
Uh,
cotton?
Yeah.
Like cotton balls if you just like,
Eh,
really?
You right?
Yeah.
Wow.
See,
I don't think I have anything like that.
I wish I had something like that though.
Something really crazy.
Yeah,
something really cool.
Speaking of partying,
I was talking,
I was telling Joe's story about Chris Leben was a friend of mine who fights up
on new years.
And,
uh,
this is one matches.
Can I tell it real quick?
Yeah,
please.
Um,
so I did a show in Hawaii on Oahu and I was a fan of Lievens and,
uh,
so I was like,
I contacted him.
I'm like,
Hey,
you wanna come out to the show?
So he's like,
yes.
He comes out to the show and Michael's get fucking drunk.
And he's like,
no.
And I'm like,
why?
He goes,
because I just,
I,
once I go there,
it's just the wheels come off and I go,
fuck you.
I gold strike.
He's like,
no.
So I'm in Hawaii for a week.
Every night I call Lee,
but I'm like,
you're a fucking con.
Let's fucking drink every night.
He's like,
no,
no.
Finally the last night,
he's like,
you know what?
You want to go big?
And I go,
yeah,
let's go fucking big.
And he's like,
all right,
I'll go big.
Literally it was like a movie cut to Lehman,
blacked out,
choked.
Two of my friends out at Dave and busters on the floor,
foaming at the mouth.
Everyone's like screaming.
He got me in a fucking show called roughly like,
uh,
some leg lock around my neck.
I'm gonna started fucking crying.
It was like complete mayhem.
Everyone was fucking terrified.
And the next day he was like,
I fucking told you dude.
And I was like,
yeah,
that's my fault too.
Wow.
This was like I'm leaving out a lot of shit cause it's just like turning up
Armageddon.
That's awful.
Like thank God his girlfriend was there and she was the only person that can
fucking talk him down.
And it was like a werewolf.
Listen to me man.
When a guy who's a cage fighter for live tells you you don't want to see me
drunk.
I know.
[inaudible] I know I'm such a fucking moron.
Rust.
And I was like a little fucking mosquito and this was like three
woo.
Just cuts it like me,
like terrified.
Oh my God dude.
Yeah.
But with Joe and I were talking about partying with fighters and stuff because
I'm a big MMA fan,
you UFC and I party with a lot of those dudes and it's just,
we have the famous mayhem story.
You were there for the mayhem still?
Yeah,
it's the first time I met him.
We went to sky bar across the street and we walk into the sky bar in,
suddenly he looks over and sees this like a bed.
You know how they have beds there with like eight girls,
I'll drink and wine and he's like gets to do a body flop.
So he runs charges,
jumps,
does a body flap on it and I just see wineglasses flying in the air and red
Merlow flying on all these people too.
And I just grabbed Joe,
me and Joe went around the corner and was just like,
what the fuck?
I'm like,
and we were like trying to distance ourselves and we look around the corner and
then he had,
he's getting taken out by security but we didn't quite go with the quote.
We backed up to the bar but we couldn't believe what he did.
He just,
we were joking around about something and he had this be just made this big lap
and then he back swan dived like backwards pop into this pile of people,
you know,
and he's fucking 200 and something pounds and he's,
he's,
it's a big fucking strong dude.
He's just one of those things where should have thought about it for a second
and then he wouldn't have done it.
And [inaudible] it goes back.
I partied with chat a lot and he's a buddy.
That doesn't surprise me.
He fucking does.
You know what's most shocking thing about that dude?
Not that he's,
you know,
an excellent fighter.
He's a really good writer.
He writes really well.
Like if you ever read his articles that he writes for fight magazine,
no.
Very smart guy,
man.
He's very bright and they're,
they're,
they're really,
they're self deprecating.
They're interesting.
They're,
he's serving,
he's very,
very observative.
Is that a word observer?
Observatory?
Is that a word?
I Dunno.
[inaudible] observative yes.
This one word,
observational apps or video.
He's makes great observations.
He's a really like,
and he's like really?
Like,
you know,
there's a lot of dudes who write about wild shit,
but they're not live in a wildlife.
He's truly live in a wildlife.
I mean it's a fucking professional cage fighter,
right?
Yeah.
And a very bright guy and a good writer.
So his stuff is interesting,
you know,
it's like here's a guy that's like talking and walking it,
man.
You know.
I remember I met him out at a club one night and he showed up with a fur coat,
no shirt underneath and two Asian girls on his arms and sound glasses.
I was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
And nicest guy you ever want to hang out with.
So Nice sometimes actually can.
Cool guy.
I was with Jay on fucking,
that's was it this weekend then missed his birthday on the day after Christmas.
Yeah.
And he goes,
I'm having a birthday party.
And I just was like,
I'm not going to that party.
Like I made the conscious choice.
I knew that it would be like once you're pot committed to that shit dude,
it is.
The wheels can come off.
Jay was like fire.
You could tell like his energy was just like through the roof.
I was like,
oh no,
but happy birthday Jay Levine.
He's a wild motherfucker.
I love that dude.
He's a crazy dude.
It's interesting having people like that in the world,
you know?
You know,
everybody tries to put everybody in a neat little box,
you know,
and then try to like,
here's the guy that's like this guy and that guy was like this guy and that
guy's every now and then you meet someone like mayhem and you go,
oh look at this mother fucker.
Where do you put him?
Where's what box is there for him?
It doesn't exist.
These super funny to,
very funny man.
I'm trying to get him to do,
he's doing stand up at the Improv soon I think.
Or is he really all he fucking did it and then call me.
I was so passed.
We did Ari show.
He did it.
He did a storyteller show.
He did Ari show and he said it was great.
So he went right.
Oh that's cool.
Yeah,
he's,
yeah,
I think it was very smart guy,
man.
He can do anything he sets his mind to.
Yeah.
I think he'd be a funny stand up.
He totally was telling
me.
He told some jokes that didn't work or no,
he said Faggot onstage.
It was a doing something.
We just kept saying faggot and he's like,
yeah,
the crowd didn't go with me on it.
I'm like,
yeah,
some tough.
And the club was in West Hollywood brow,
a little tough,
you know,
he said he's going to stop saying that word too.
We had them on the podcast.
He talked about,
not saying faggot anymore,
but I mean the fact
word that I've a new bit my act about where I'd say that faggots shouldn't be,
do use to describe gay people.
It should be used to describe cats.
When can she is aware of such fucking faggots.
It's just bullshit.
Love it.
You know what I mean?
It's a great word.
Unfortunate such a fucking good word,
but it's like right word,
but it's such a hot topic.
You know?
It's touchy about it,
but it's like,
if you don't,
if you don't point at,
I've fucking gated and be like Yara off.
Fuck.
I like,
that's offensive.
You know what I mean?
But if you're like,
yeah,
my truck,
my car,
they broke down,
my car is a fucking faggot.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like why is that a,
it's problem is,
it's funny.
I know.
It's like the funniest word to say in that situation.
I mean,
it makes a Jew,
you know,
if you like,
I used to have this joke where called my dog a faggot.
Oh really?
Yeah,
because it was about the number,
that pot commercial with the dog starts talking to the CIC and tells them smoke
weed in the jug called the dog a faggot.
Cause that's like the funniest thing he could say to your dog,
fucking faggot.
Like,
who are you talking to?
Stupid.
You're telling me to stop smoking weed?
Yeah.
You're a dog.
He dumb cunt.
Yeah.
It's like if you,
yeah.
If I,
if I,
if I'm,
if I'm like my shoes a con.
Yeah.
I've popped my cuts through the roof ever since I stopped saying faggot.
I've been saying [inaudible] like crazy.
Everyone's a continent and I'm kind of enjoying it.
That's a tough one to pull off on stage,
so it's fine.
Let it go.
Nah,
I called people content stage all the time.
There's that.
You know what if it really,
if you,
you're going to get offended by me calling someone a cunt or saying something's
a con in a,
in stand up comedy,
you're not,
you're the wrong show.
When people go to live shows,
this is for people out there.
I mean your fans already fucking know this,
but like you can't go to a show.
You get a friend and be a fucking effect.
It's like the stupidest fucking thing.
Yeah,
it's there.
You're there to have,
just try to go along.
Just if you,
if you're seeing good comedy,
just go along.
Just have a good fucking time.
You don't have to agree with everything the person saying,
just have fun,
just have fun and relax and if you don't like it,
leave.
Don't let us leave.
Don't be a cunt.
Dude.
I,
this is a corrillion a quick story that just happened to me that you'll fucking
love.
I do this.
Talk about toys for tots,
benefit at the fucking Improv.
I'm already hammered.
So I show up the club and I show up late,
so I walk in,
it's packed,
you know what I mean?
And I showed up late and I fucking go and I go on stage and I have a joke in my
act about old people and I'm like,
you know,
it's stuck to be like 95 years old because you can fucking die every time you go
to bed.
So it's like hard to plan your next day because it's like you can't really make
plans all the time because if like your grandson,
like let's go to the zoo,
it's like,
okay,
I'll leave it,
go to the zoo with you or I'll be fucking dead.
So like hopefully I'll go to the zoo,
but either you'll come over and I'll be a dead body and people will scream and
cry.
We awful.
You know what I mean?
So I do all bet and I'm like,
my sets going really good.
And I do that joke and the fucking crowd just goes like dead silent.
And I'm like,
what the fuck?
yeah,
you can fucking die for fucking 95 I just do this whole bet.
And I'm like,
yeah.
And the crowd's getting more and more uncomfortable and Ip people like groaning
and I'm like,
what the fuck's?
The joke always works and I get off stage and I was like really uncomfortable
and it turned out it was a 95 year old woman's birthday party,
a friend of Bud Friedman's.
They went on stage at the beginning of the show,
which I didn't see and made a huge announcement saying happy birthday to her.
The whole crowd just thought I was like some psycho asshole.
I was just like,
you can die any fucking day if you're 95 when you go to bed.
Like it was so uncommon.
Love how you're saying that with your fist up to your face.
The microphone.
Yeah,
that is the offensive microphone fits.
If you're saying something really crazy,
listen,
you whore,
you will have your fist in a certain position.
Tilting the gun sight.
Exactly.
It's gangster dude.
Bud came over to me.
He's like,
my God.
I don't know if you knew this,
but it was
so and so's 95th birthday in case you're wondering whether that joke didn't
work.
Oh,
I felt so bad.
I go,
she bombed out and he goes,
no,
she couldn't.
You
hear anything she can't hear.
So I was like,
oh,
thank God everybody else's bombed out.
The crown was just,
I was so uncomfortable and I fell off of it cause I'm not insensitive like that.
I would of course not.
That's terrible.
I've done,
there's a joke that I do and every time I get to it,
like I see like I'm always like about the sad and I'll see a fat girl in the
audience and then I won't pull the trigger.
I stopped saying,
I like,
I don't want to be mean.
I used to have this joke about chicks,
like people would see like a,
a really overweight chick and a little slutty outfit and let girls were always
hitting.
It's like,
what the fuck is she thinking?
And I would go,
I'll tell you exactly what she's thinking.
It might not be the best ride,
but there's no line
that would be right about to do that.
But all the time,
look in the audience to see a poor fat girl who's having a good time isn't it?
But she's got her fingers folded up and they're chubby lap and she's laughing
her ass off and I don't want to crush her emotion.
So I just dance over the bed for one person,
I'll just say,
sorry,
that's good.
But every now and then man,
there'll be a joke and I'll say it and then I'll turn and like,
oh here's an example of my joke
now I feel bad again.
I saw that recently added Jim Jeffrey show and I just,
I was just like,
I was sitting on the side of the stage,
just staring right in front of me was a fat chick.
You just see you're just staring the whole bit.
And then like just like sitting there like looking down on the ground or
handling like
almost in tears to really obese people are so sensitive because there's,
this is so many people fucking staring at him all the time.
They look like freaks.
That's gotta be,
it's so painful.
And then when someone's shitting on fat people and everyone around you is
laughing and there you are and feel bad.
Go home and eat.
But yeah,
probably right.
I don't,
I don't do my joke with old people anymore.
If I ever see an old couple in the crowd,
they look like 70s or 80s I won't even do it.
Just cause I fucking feel it's a terrible feeling man.
My parents are in their sixties they don't like talking about death.
They don't even like the mentioned fucking parents in his sixties yeah.
Holy Shit.
Your pants and younger.
Yeah.
Well my mom was really young when she had me and my stepfather was younger than
my mom.
My mom was like,
I think she was like close to 30 when she met my stepfather and he was 24 or
something like that.
So yeah.
So they're very young and they don't like talking about that
90 year old people.
They don't want to hear none of that shit.
They want to hear dead people jokes.
They did not want to shore.
Let me see.
Shorts to always get mad at me at the comedy store cause I would do that joke
about j Howard Marshall.
J Howard Marshall is the old man that married Anna Nicole Smith.
That billionaire though.
Yeah,
I know what it was.
Do this choke hold him just doing all sorts of nasty shit to her before he dies.
I don't even remember how Joe,
I don't even remember how the goes,
but I do remember that I would get off stage and mid to go.
Y'All doing y'all?
I'd be like Mitzi.
It's funny.
I think that took meanwhile was my closer.
Okay.
It was a washer and it was a crusher of a bit that I could even follow.
I couldn't follow it.
I have to close on that bit.
She was like,
I know.
Like it stomped on his nap.
Stop.
Do Your fucking huge closer.
That's a great,
well,
you know it was about old people and cheese,
you know,
just can't know all long in those years.
But it's like,
it's not uncomfortable
for Ernie to talk about old people.
Like,
some people get mad at me when I do that and I'm like,
I'm going to fucking get old.
Hopefully.
I mean,
I might not,
I'll probably forget.
Right.
But when you go,
I can't avoid it,
you know what I mean?
So it's like essentially I'm talking about myself because we're all gonna get,
we all get old.
It's not like I took some fucking potion and now I'm a cocky lived forever guy
who's like,
ah,
yeah,
that is a trick.
Like different,
it's like,
why can't you make fun of that?
Because it really is a valid subject.
I stand up,
stand up as genius.
He used to do like that.
He would go after old people and he like,
he would do jokes about like fucking succulent,
you know,
getting a blow job and the Collagen and comfortable it'd be all people in the
crowd.
And I don't remember Doug.
It'd be like,
you fucking asshole fucking crowd.
You guys are thick.
You're so fucking better.
This guy's fucking knew.
How old are you?
So it'd be like 81 this guy was fucking getting his dick sucked before you guys
were fucking born.
He's like,
you think you guys invented the blow job?
He goes,
fuck you.
Fuck this crowd.
This guy's a fighter who just go off to the crowd just like,
oh my God.
It was like,
oh awesome.
That's fine.
Yeah.
It's a touchy subject for people that are getting old subjects real touchy man.
People don't want to,
you know,
well they forget it.
Old People like it just makes people uncomfortable,
you know,
start shitting on old people and they're like something you can even change.
At least you're fat.
You can lose weight if you're old,
you're fucked.
I stopped,
I stopped doing comedy for five years when the day Bob hope died.
I went onstage and did that Bob hope joke and it was like like a year or two
after nine 11 good one.
Our troops were like going,
you know,
being sent to Iraq and stuff and Bob hope died and I thought it was like an open
mic or,
and I'm like,
oh I'm going on.
I really,
you did this new Bob Hope
joke and I'd come out on stage and it was just all old people cause at the funny
bone in Columbus,
Ohio,
they gave tickets out to like senior citizens and stuff like that and so I went
out and like,
do I do this joke?
I'm like,
yeah,
I have to have,
you know.
And it was a,
hey,
did you guys hear Bob Hope died?
And they're were like,
oh.
And like everyone's just like Ah,
you know,
like sad and making sad noises.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I heard they flew out his body to entertain all the dead troops and they just
started hissing and booing and I didn't do comedy for five years.
Do Omari Good Joe,
I'm sorry.
That's a good joke though.
Insanity.
That was a good joke dude.
Did you open with it?
No,
it was like my third joke in or fourth joke,
someone,
Jesus and then I just stopped.
I just stopped even to watch Bob Hope.
Do standup comedy.
I don't think I have actually I was the on premium blend.
No,
he was on half hour comedy hour.
I thought it was golf Cabana.
What's the volume for the clover?
That old,
I'm kind of comedy that old like Bob Hope style comedy.
That's a fascinating thing to watch.
That's like if you ever wanted to see like evolution,
you want to see,
you want to see fish that eventually walk on land.
Watch some Bob hope comedy from like 1950.
I met him when I was eight years old.
He,
uh,
came up to me and signed autograph for me at a field and then he wrote that
joke.
He's like,
tell him it was crazy booed off stage about me and 20 years from now it was
awesome.
And it's this big crowd of people.
And I was just a little kid and then he just walked by and looked at me and he's
like,
went right to me.
Signed it and he said something to me and then walked off until you do you uh,
what the fuck was I going to say?
Nick Swardson only person here not hi.
By the way,
hangovers worse than high.
No all.
Do you know who he was or no?
Yeah.
Cause I think we need grew up with like four channels on the TV.
He always had those marathons or something like that.
Well always did the USO thing,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I used to actually like him.
I remember liking him,
like remembering him from TV and let's,
okay,
cause I don't remember any,
it was comedy.
This is why I'm saying this.
I'm saying,
you know what I do remember is I remember watching a long time ago and going,
wow,
this is like a window into a different era.
Like the way people clapped was different,
or the studio audience looked different.
That comedy was different.
The way the announcer would introduce him was different.
Pull up some,
some of his shit.
Pull up some Bob Hope.
Stand up.
You know,
it's crazy.
Every time I drive home from here,
I exit off of Bob Hope Drive.
Oh Shit.
No stalkers are going to know where you live.
How about that?
That's an area.
Burbank,
they're going to know girls.
You're gonna get some girls stalkers.
Let me fuck.
What time is it?
Football game,
dude.
Um,
shit balls.
Your mother's coat.
But correct.
What time was the football game?
I don't like,
I don't follow football.
Football is boring.
My team placed,
you know they're going to institute sensors in,
in helmets.
You hear that?
Oh,
I can sell all this shit that's leaking.
Yeah.
No,
they're going to find out like what the fuck's going to happen when
they blast each other in the head.
Oh No.
Sensors.
How much censor their helmets?
No,
no,
no.
Why?
What are they saying?
Oh Dude,
you can cut some fucking hilarious shits.
I'm really sort through.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
Like what?
They swear.
Oh yeah,
dude.
So you watch them once in a while you could catch like a fan will pick up some
shit.
Um,
some receiver job,
like an n bomb the other day.
Really?
Yeah.
Black Guy or white guy?
No,
the black dude.
You'll see that there was Michael Richards just got drafted by the bangles.
The coach from the 49,
or is that that last game?
Uh,
you know,
he,
I think he just got fired or something.
It's got fired and he was,
he was yelling at one of the players at the quarterback was like,
I'm sorry I can't do any better or something.
Whoa,
I'm just human.
Or something like that.
I was fucked up.
Player was signal to who's yelling at the player?
Yeah.
Was like,
she,
they got in a huge fight.
Mike Singletary did,
he used to play for the bears.
Here's the defensive player for the bears out.
He was sick and he was the one that was in a like the Superbowl shovel sick,
sick,
good or sick aids.
He was sick.
Good.
You can't burp aids and then leave me in the dark luck.
Sorry about that.
Um,
no,
he was,
he was awesome.
Was he at the Superbowl shuffle team?
Wasn't even one of those guys you might've been,
yeah,
that's what came into prominence anymore after I think more after that.
And so just a crazy coach and just yells and screams and coach the coached 40
niners and they were just start fucking before names are a mess.
There's fucking,
and he had a press conference and literally he wears a huge wooden cross around
his neck every game.
Huge.
It looks like how big.
It's like,
hey bro.
No,
it's like fucking,
oh my God.
Like that.
Plenty.
It looks you really?
Yeah.
I mean it could be like a crucifix for like a fucking cat or something.
You could fuck.
You know what I mean?
It's big dam and so he got fired and then he said him and his wife are going to
take a step back and pray about it and see what they're going to do next.
Nice.
It's like what?
It's always a good move.
Here's some Bob Hope.
Give me some Bob Hope.
[inaudible]
thank you very much.
Uh,
uh,
I wish she'd get steady work.
Okay.
That's my joke.
So it's nice to see her.
I haven't,
I haven't been traveling too much lately and I've gotten to know some of the
family personally.
That's nice to be here
Dane.
And I wanted to tell you that I'm happy that NBC is the Bob Hope Rose for
another year.
[inaudible] I you love the way
Dan reads cue cards.
If he doesn't like the joke,
he breezed on it and the racism,
it was nice to flip
is that all of them
want to see him before without high heels.
Is that in?
Thank you for that.
Um,
no,
I really miss flip series,
but he has to face the facts.
He's good.
But he's no Sonny Bono.
I guess that was a dishonest Sonny
and I do want to thank governor Reagan for his kind words.
Incidentally,
the governor had presidential aspirations.
In fact,
you just made a tour of 43 states just to tell him he's not running for any
[inaudible]
girls here.
Milton was the first comic.
Do ever be impeached
Johnny
greatest catcher of all time.
Do you ever see him behind the plate?
He wears more padding than Phyllis Diller.
[inaudible]
you do?
He doesn't care about baseball.
He just stands in the hall out here watching the chicks and smiling.
She would smile too if you spent all your afternoons on grass
grasp
marijuana.
Yeah,
but the girl who inspired that great movies,
psycho
[inaudible]
since she had that operation,
it's a miracle.
It was over a year ago on the stitches on the writers still holding
[inaudible].
I wasn't John Wayne
wonderful in his next sequel to true grit.
John is really giving us a thrill.
Topical.
He's wearing the patch over his mouth
and sugar ray.
There's one of my great,
great favorites.
Everyone knows about the great job.
You're doing sugar with your youth foundation,
football,
baseball,
boxing,
basketball.
You taught those kids how to bet on all of them.
Less sugar ray Robinson sign.
Oh my God,
it's old school.
Last time I worked with ginger was on a Christmas trip to Alaska.
She not only stole the show,
but she replaced two electric blankets.
Thank you,
Ben Graham.
What a crazy dance
via radio,
television,
and heaven
in general.
Jimmy Stewart here as usual.
Jimmy's a man of few words and even fewer laughs.
Jay,
they had me over to his house last weekend.
What a thrilling evening.
He showed slides of his last trip to Fresno
[inaudible].
Oh,
that's nice to see.
Josh Ya.
Now that she's free again.
I'm sorry.
I should've said divorced.
She'd never been free.
[inaudible]
ladies and gentleman by General.
Bradley's presence here this evening.
You're talk about great generals on June the 11th 1944 he was parachuted behind
enemy lines and under cover of night,
snuck into the heart of Berlin and single handedly captured Marlena Dietrich's
garter belt.
[inaudible]
you were really up there tonight.
You keep it up and you'd be pumping gas for Chico and the man
[inaudible]
Gotcha
news today.
He was made poster boy for Tidy Bowl.
Yeah.
Can figure out why you're doing commercials for right guard.
You should be on for rate.
Rosie,
ladies and gentlemen,
it's been a great night.
Do you know somebody once said,
you can measure a man by the caliber of his enemies and I flat on my shelf to
believe it might also apply to the friends who would come to roasting nev.
I am right in that assumption and it is rare that I'm am not,
Huh.
Thank all of you.
Giants of our business for the size,
your affection of malice lens to me.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
pretty fucking good.
Yeah,
he's good.
Interesting.
Please do.
I'm sorry.
Don't,
don't apologize.
You were,
you were here for an hour and 30 minutes of Goddamn polarity.
That was one to four.
It is very fun.
I'll come back anytime.
Anytime you want to come,
man.
Please do.
Um,
all right,
well we're not going to end the podcast right now,
so what we'll do is we'll stop and then we'll come back with just me and Brian
and we'll close this bitch out.
But right now nick Swardson is all up out of here and you are not on Twitter,
correct?
I'm not on Twitter,
but I have a Facebook fan page.
And how do you get to that?
What is the address of it?
Um,
it just put an x words.
It's a picture of me with sunglasses on and a mustache.
It's definitely you.
Yeah.
Okay,
sure.
Out there all the time.
Hey,
can you update it all the time?
But why don't you Twitter then?
What's the matter?
I don't know.
I'll figure Twitter out.
Fuck Bro.
Goddammit.
All right,
do it.
We're going to get them on Twitter.
We'll get them on.
Just like we got bill on sort of just made like three Twitter posts ever.
We've got a monitor fucking bar.
Um,
all right guys.
Thanks for dude.
You were awesome.
Thank you very much nick.
swardson.com is that what it,
what's your website?
[inaudible] dot com if you want to get the whole you Facebook Facebook fan page,
we will be right back.
Next gonna leave.
We'll be right back.
The Sun's going down.
[inaudible] the tickets.
Fun and Nice Lady.
Uber sheets.
A lot of candles.
[inaudible] so lucky lager baby can switch back and forth.
Half and half circle on my jeans all day and night.
But genes don't care if you're black.
Hey Yo.
Why
grab some buddies?
Get drunk at shoot skeet then black out and let him suck the lot Martine.
[inaudible] calf.
Nah,
too hard.
You're not a jerk.
[inaudible]
suck.
You suck at j j J.
Dot.
J.
Gail [inaudible].
Now [inaudible] fight it then take your thing.
Pay.
Take Beta tape
sober up.
Go back to the bar.
Z.
Your beautiful lady.
Excuse me.
What is stuck Sushi for lunch.
What do you dike
that proposition for your son?
What is it?
What are you coming back to?
La Plays Deck
that just [inaudible] dot saga.
That's mad milk baby.
It'll help you sleep.
Nick Swardson bad motherfucker.
You know,
one of the coolest things about this business,
about,
about being in the a standup comedy businesses,
all the fun fucking people you meet,
you know?
Yeah.
Nick,
me and one of them.
Yeah.
Such a fucking good dude.
When we think about just this podcast,
all the cool people that we've hung out with on this podcast,
you know,
half fron and you know,
Johnny Pemberton,
I would've never known about him if it wasn't for the podcast.
Right?
Yup.
You know,
Freddie La card and you know,
t been so many fucking cool people were so fortunate,
man.
Totally.
That's one of the big problems that a lot of people face in their life is that
there,
there's not enough cool people to hang out with.
They're just always around.
Douche bags are always around negative energy and it's so hard to have a good
time.
We're so fucking lucky,
man.
Yeah.
It's usually like if you,
I mean back in Ohio and stuff,
I've got most of your friends came from where you worked and so like you were
like,
I would work a lot at restaurants.
All my friends were like other waiters and just people that needed a job and
you'd go through so many friends so fast.
It was more like you're dating friends,
you know?
You know,
and you would like hang out with them and shit and go out with them after work.
And then some weird shit would go down where you realize one guy couldn't drink
right.
Fucking crazy or something bad happens that they steal a VCR from you.
[inaudible] why did you see my VCR?
Yeah.
You see people who are banging each other.
It's always people working together.
Waitresses and waiters are,
he's trying to see who's going to hook up and yeah,
that's hilarious.
You know so many people,
man,
they're,
they're in unfortunate situations where they can't find enough cool people.
That's tricky.
Absolutely.
We've got to start a cult,
Brian [inaudible]
cool.
Thinking about this lately.
I'm,
what can I call it?
The you want to reprogram people?
Isolation tanks,
eating pot brownies,
everybody watching good documentaries.
Everybody getting their shit together.
Martial arts,
yoga,
eat healthy.
Clean your fucking brain out of bullshit.
We're going to fix this world.
Brian.
Mouthwash in your car.
Yes,
hand sanitizer.
You get pulled over.
Don't use sanitizer over your hands and your face.
Don't smoke weed in your car.
Stupid.
You know.
No Smoking in the car.
That was like a big joke with Joey.
Yeah,
cause Joey Dee has always wanting smoke weed in the car and we're like,
dude,
we're going to get pulled over.
We're in
Texas in the car,
thinks like we and it's California weed and they can smell the difference.
It's crazy how you forget that.
Like in Ohio,
that was a scary thing.
Driving with weed or buying food and stuff.
I remember always being a paranoid,
don't do it.
You can go to jail.
Now I go to back home to Ohio and I'm just like,
hey,
here's some weeds.
There's a joint is don't do that.
Then they'll lock you up.
They locked up.
Willie Nelson,
Bro.
Yeah.
Stop and think about that.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's weird when you like watch cops too.
Like I was watching cops either day in this,
it was police cops have at uh,
Texas or whatever that shows called like female t Dallas Female Cox,
the show.
It's like cops.
But with these Dallas female girls,
it's like real housewives of Atlanta and mixed with cops.
But anyways,
it's real though supposedly.
And uh,
they were shaking down somebody like for having like a little bit of weed.
They're like,
you understand you are driving with marijuana,
sir.
Do you have like making it seem like it was just insane drug,
you know?
And it was just,
wait a second,
this is just weed.
He had a little bit of a week,
you know,
that's weird to me that that's that,
most states that's how they treat wheat and that's how you're yelled at upon
from the police officers and stuff.
And now here,
not always out here,
man.
There's some dopey cops out here too.
I mean,
most cops are really cool,
but there's,
there's a few,
it's like everybody else,
you know.
One douchebag.
Cop makes everybody think cops are douchebags cops aren't all douchebags.
Most cops that I know from,
I know him from Jujitsu and I know him from martial arts.
So fucking Nice guys,
man.
The most that I know,
it's just a job man.
They're trying to do the best they can at this fucking crazy job.
But every now and one,
and then you run into a Twat and uh,
my friend got,
he got pulled over.
What happened was he was in his car and um,
somehow or another someone saw like,
like,
uh,
he,
like he had a,
a joint in his hand or something and the cop,
like he didn't realize there was cops there and the cop flashed him and he was
just putting it back and it was car.
And the cop said,
you know,
you're not,
why do you have marijuana when you're operating a car?
And he's like,
I'm not even smoking it before I get in the car.
And they handcuffed him.
Chicken was yelling at him.
Well,
he turns out he was a medical marijuana patient,
so it was really like his little medicine.
I mean if you want to pay attention to state laws,
which is the cops are supposed to do,
right.
But this chick was beat rating him and yelling at him and I'm like,
this is so gross.
Because I was watching it because it was right outside of Jujitsu class was when
we were at the old legends and we would leave.
There was like this alleyway and you would go down the alleyway,
everybody would walk towards where the cars are parked.
And there was a cop car there and I guess this kid didn't see the cop car,
but it was like listening to the way this woman was talking to him as if he had
done something to her.
You know,
you know,
you don't know what the law is apparently you don't know what the law is,
you know?
Do you read what it says on this piece of paper says do not operate heavy
machinery.
And she's like in his face and shit and he's handcuffed and it was so gross.
And I was like,
what are you talking about?
First of all,
the guys not high,
he just told you he's getting,
he just got out of the gym.
Okay.
So he's got a joint in his hand.
Like what are you doing?
Like what exactly.
And by the way you can drive high.
There's been a lot of studies on it.
I don't recommend it.
I don't think it's for everybody because a lot of people get fucking paranoid as
shit when they're driving or when they're stoned rather and they can't
concentrate on anything and they see in tunnel vision and they'll miss
peripheral shit.
Right.
I mean maybe not the best thing for everybody,
but it's not like driving drunk,
you know,
drunk is completely awful.
I mean sometimes when you think about how horrible,
like I'm the worst.
Once in awhile I'll let myself slip where it gets to a point where I,
I do a shot I shouldn't have done or I had an extra drink that I shouldn't have
and I'll catch myself going,
man,
why?
Why am I,
you know,
have to drive now.
What the fuck not to do it.
Usually I try to find food like on the way like you know,
stop somewhere to eat.
But there's been those times,
you know where you're just like,
man,
I'm just going to drive home.
I try this.
And then the next day you're like,
why the fuck did I do drive yourself to a diner or don't?
That's what I usually take a cab to a diner,
go fuel up on that thing is often,
I'm saying it's very,
very rare but scary shit man.
Cause people who kill people in drunk driving accidents and people who get away
with it are really doing the same thing.
Just one person fucks up and you know,
happens to be in the wrong place,
the wrong time and the other person just gets lucky and doesn't hit anything on
the way home.
But a lot of that is just just dumb luck man.
Yeah.
Scary shit man.
The idea that you can get that anywhere.
I mean you can go to cvs and drink enough alcohol to die.
That's crazy.
That's so crazy.
Man at cvs even sells beer in it's like has the best deals on beer,
whiskey or liquor and beer at cvs.
It seems like cvs is supposed to help you and it makes no sense that I never
would've thought that that's crazy that they to see.
Yeah,
that's supposed to be like a hospital almost,
you know with gum,
right?
If you want anything that's gonna make you feel better.
If you're sick,
dude,
I got some therapy theraflu when I went to Montreal,
I got,
I got the flu.
When I came back I was,
I was fucking wrecked for like a full two days.
I was wrecked right where I was like cold sweats and shivers.
Like I was freezing.
I was sweating like my whole body was sweating and I was shaking and it was
freezing and I was wearing clothes to bed.
I was wearing like pants and jackets and hoods.
Terrible feeling,
right?
Terrible fuel.
I drank some Theraflu,
boom,
knocked it out of the park.
I mean knocked it out of the park.
No chills,
slept like a baby.
I don't know how much of it is a theraflu and how much of it is my immune
system.
I eat really healthy.
My immune system bounces back pretty quick or I don't know if that's it,
but I think it's the Theraflu.
I think the Theraflu just kind of masked the,
the,
the feeling and it's the same shit in there that you make meth out.
You can make meth at a theraflu dude.
No,
Mrs Rogan had a sign for it when she went and bought it for me.
You have to show your id to she Shabaka and finally three boxes at their flu.
You gotta show your ID and sign for that shit.
I didn't know that,
but it's dope.
Theraflu is the shit.
I like that shit.
I can't,
I don't even know what it is.
And there's no way I could even pronounce it,
but there it's from like Germany or something like that.
It's like a really long name.
Like Petco,
you know,
and you're talking about and it's like you take 10 of these oil,
Iran,
it's us silly sub bill seminomas.
Yeah,
it's like little,
you know,
like half sugar beads.
It feels like,
I think it might be bullshit.
I did it once and it worked.
It seemed like it worked.
But again,
but then again,
you don't know this isn't working or is it,
Ari sent me something the other day that said that some insane amount of people,
uh,
that they give,
um,
the,
uh,
that they give placebos to the placebo effect works.
Even if,
you know it's a placebo apparently.
Really,
I don't understand how that works,
but what Ari said was that they told people that they were going to give them a
placebo and even just telling them that they were going to give them a placebo
made them heal up quicker than people that they didn't tell.
Well,
it's probably because they didn't know what placebo means.
That it sounds like something like skin cell mine that gave him some placebo.
Man,
that Shit's legit.
You know,
maybe they just didn't know what it was.
I don't know.
What they're saying
is.
Um,
well everyone was aware of the placebo effect in medicine where a person
believes in sugar pills.
He's taken as a real medicine and sees improvement in symptoms.
Is it possible to experience the placebo effect even if you know the medicine
isn't real according to one new study and Plos one,
I don't know what that means.
The answer is yes.
So it's interesting.
ADP 80 people that did it with and it showed more people got better with the
placebo.
The fuck knows.
It's a weird thing,
man,
that your brain's got this ability to heal itself,
that you can't really tap into that.
But if it thinks that you're getting some medicine,
then it just fixes it.
Right?
Who?
Hell,
what the fuck is that about?
It's like your belief is so fucking strong.
It's so important to believe in things,
man.
So important in a weird way that doesn't make any sense.
You know there's,
there's like a zone when you believe in things and you're,
you're,
you're really like,
you're confident and you're tuned into him.
There's a weird power to that.
And you know,
he experienced that man,
experienced that in video games and experiencing that when you're playing pool,
you experience,
there's a ban on experience side and pulled up.
But Jesus,
cause you don't get that good at it.
When you get really good at pool,
you experience the,
these,
these zones where you believe in yourself and the ball just you believe
everything,
everything goes well.
But if you,
if you have,
um,
a negative thought at all,
like you could be aiming at the ball the perfect way you could queue up.
You know,
you've got a good bridge,
you're,
you're relaxed and the way you're gripping it,
everything you strokes in line.
But if right before you shoot it,
you start thinking,
I hope I don't miss this.
You'll miss it like eight times out of 10.
And now sometimes it'll babile it's way in,
but you really were supposed to miss it.
You know,
it's,
it's a weird thing,
man.
It's like when you believe it goes in,
it's so strange.
You know,
it doesn't work if you don't know how to play.
But once you learn how to play,
it's like one of the most important things is that not have a negative thought
before you pull the trigger before you shoot.
They say that's the same thing with archery as well.
You know that you have to kind of like have this belief in what you're doing and
if you don't,
even if you're doing everything the right way,
if you don't believe it's going to hit it,
it won't hit.
Did they still do archery and like elementary school?
I don't think they trust kids with bows and arrows out where to go.
I was thinking that the other day I was like no.
I remember
in elementary school like fifth grade having arrows and bows and we had like
these like courses that you go through and try to kind of like,
you know,
a shooting range where you'd walk through and just do archery everywhere.
And I remember thinking like one time I already shot it straight up in the air
and I remember how dumb that was cause I didn't really think it out.
Franciscans.
Yeah,
do that shit.
Super Dangerous.
Yeah.
When I was 12 I was in the boy scouts and uh,
I went on a camp,
I went to like a camp for two weeks.
Then we were shooting guns,
man,
we're shooting guns and you'd hear ricochets like we were,
I was in the archery course and this is one of the reasons why I decided to just
quit everything and go fishing.
The whole time I was there,
all I did was go fishing everyday.
I quit everything.
I was like,
fuck you crazy assholes.
Because we were all shooting archery and I hurt.
I was like,
what the fuck is that?
And then someone,
one of the kids goes,
that's a ricochet.
What do you mean a ricochet?
Someone had shot and it probably hit a rock or something.
Get the fuck Outta here,
man.
We almost just got hit by a bullet.
Okay.
What is going on here?
And it was only at 22.
So if it did hit you in a ricocheted,
probably just could be,
he could hit your eye,
you know,
I mean you could get fucked up.
So I was like,
these crazy ass holes.
I'm just going to go fishing every day,
so I avoided all the activities.
I didn't go,
I didn't do anything.
I just went fishing.
We would all get in line like everybody get in line,
I just disappear into the woods.
Somebody could easily raped and killed me.
Man.
It's like no one was watching us for two weeks.
I was alone in the woods of New Hampshire.
No one was watching anybody.
These fucking counselors who knows what kind of creepy shit they were into.
Right?
They always had a few boys that they really liked the most and they hung out
with them and then everybody else would just kind of like free like a little
wild animals,
little 12 year olds with no cell phones.
There's not even a phone out there period.
My parents had no way to contact me and you're out there alone in the woods with
a bunch of fucking street kids.
They're all kids from Jamaica plain,
which is like this really shitty area of Boston.
And so they were all like fucking doing deviant shit in the middle of the night,
like taking kids out into the woods and tying them to their bed and leaving them
in the woods and covering them with toothpaste,
whether they're sleeping.
It was like,
it was fucking creepy.
It was like being in like,
like a,
a juvenile detention center in the woods.
There was a weird Google that I did the other day that I always googling and see
what time Kmart was open to.
And Somehow I ended up,
uh,
on this website about this a Kmart that's by my house that,
um,
I suspect tried to murder two police officers and shot two police officers at
Kmart in Burbank,
which is like,
Eh,
who,
who has,
you know,
violence there.
But,
uh,
so anyways,
what,
what's weird,
I started,
I was so stoned,
I decided just to,
cause that was back in July and they started to try to read up.
And if you go online and read about this,
uh,
just Google,
Kmart shooting murder or police officer or whatever,
uh,
it starts off,
you know,
saying how this guy was like shoplifting and then,
some security guards like,
uh,
were there trying to hold this guy down and then he like pulls out the offy,
grabs the officer's gun while being handcuffed or something like that.
But anyways,
what's weird about this is there's message boards where the wife of this guy is
saying,
you know,
this is all bullshit.
This is,
you know,
in my,
my husband's none,
you know,
none of this happened or something weird.
Like I can't remember what it was,
but I was really big.
But,
uh,
he has like two kids,
but if he noticed this story never,
like there's no news about it.
Like he was supposed to go to trial and stuff and now there's like,
this guy just got banished from like the news and from public records and stuff.
Like,
did you research it?
I researched it for about 10,
15 minutes on Google,
which,
you know,
what does that mean?
You type in,
there's no story.
It doesn't mean the guy advantage because the system is bogged down with so many
other cases.
If you're that bored,
just started doing a little digging on this guy and started going to some of
these message boards that come up on Google and it's kind of weird cause like
the wife is involved with all these message boards and stuff.
It's kind of crazy.
Yeah.
That is kind of crazy.
Here's another crazy thing.
Uh,
did you hear about this guy who got busted for hacking into his wife's email?
[inaudible] apparently this dude is married to his chick and she's only 33 and
she's been married three times already.
So you know,
if there's,
pitch is crazy.
Right,
right.
And apparently she was taking their daughter over to her ex husband's house,
so she was banging her second husband and taken his daughter over to her second
husband's house in second husband.
He used to beat the shit out of her apparently.
So he's guys freaking out like about his daughter might be in danger.
You know,
this guy beat the shit out of his wife.
So he,
he hacks into her email to find out all this information.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
I think somehow or another he got her password that's hacking into it.
I mean it might've been as simple as she left the shit on,
you know,
on her Google password over,
just say a monitor on who knows what the fuck,
what the fuck really happened.
Right.
Attacking.
But anyway,
she,
she gets into this and finds out or he gets into this rather and finds out that
she's cheating.
So,
uh,
he,
um,
tries to get her,
uh,
her,
you know,
tries to get child support,
tries to get a custody rather,
and she sues him for um,
attacking or hacking into your email and this mother fucker is going to jail.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's like,
he's going to jail for some violation of some sort of a law.
Um,
I don't,
I don't know exactly what the law is,
but okay.
It has allowed to Spca sounding while ever.
Its Megan's law.
I don't understand what the law,
yeah,
I don't,
I mean,
what is the law?
I don't know.
I mean,
if someone's emails there and you know,
if you find out their password,
you know,
and you find out that they're doing some shit,
that's not,
yeah.
Especially when like what is this?
Like what's this hacking part?
Because that's retarded.
If your girlfriend uses your laptop and she stays logged in and then you just
turn on your computer and go hit her emails right there.
Yeah.
The pay.
Is that considered hacking?
Yeah,
it's apparently
the,
the prosecutors relied on a Michigan statute that was previously used to
prosecute people who committed identity theft or they stole trade secrets.
What does that like?
Typewriter ribbon ribbon,
you know,
like,
no,
no identity,
any
theft online.
You know,
there's,
the law was created to stop identity theft online.
Right.
And so when they,
when they did that,
um,
the,
you know,
they,
they entered into this case,
they use that law.
But that's like disingenuous because that's not what's going on.
This is a married couple.
This isn't someone stealing someone's identity.
This is shitty.
It seems like that would be a law that is like all your Maryborough,
sorry,
heat.
You're allowed to own this person if you really want to.
How is,
how is reading an email different from reading a letter that's left around
right,
or a text message.
Like if you find a box of letters on your wife's bed and she's going to visit
some guy at prison and sucking his dick and I like,
you'd be like,
Whoa Damn Lincoln have to deal with this shit.
You know?
And especially like call it identity theft.
You can't call it identity theft if someone finds your diary.
Maybe that's why people wrote in cursive.
So it's kind of like,
you know,
to confuse people and like hide it.
Cause like I don't want you to read my letters.
I'm going to make it hard for you to read.
No Brian,
they wrote it in cursive because it's easier to write cursive that an to make
each individual letters.
He as they flow together and say this time I went,
I went,
I had did that open mic the other day and like I had to read the list of comics
to come up and a few of them still used cursive and it just boggled my mind was
like,
wait,
you're,
you're a straight male.
Right.
Why don't you just write some shit in Aramaic,
which is penises and draw your picture.
Yeah.
What is up with cursive?
I don't even um,
change my caps.
I use all,
uh,
I use all uppercase,
upper and lowercase.
What am I doing?
If I'm writing you something,
if I need to be expressive and something that I write and it's not going to be a
little letter writing me,
I'm writing something down.
If I'm writing something down 99.9% of the time it was either from me or I'm
filling out a customs form cause I'm landing in Canada or something like that.
You know,
I just use all capitals.
when the fuck I'm saying we should mention that our podcast,
it was picked in the top 10 of a iTunes.
Itunes chose like top 10,
uh,
audio podcast for 2010 and we're in there,
you know,
we've got to figure out something to do with this that's profitable.
Brian,
you've got to figure out how to make money with this podcast.
It's ridiculous.
All right,
we've got to figure out,
we've got to figure out how to turn this into some sort of a television show.
Well,
you know like companies like the CTO water.
Yes.
He told water center was holding up water free coconut water.
Thank you very much.
And apparently the other company,
yeah,
Amy and Brian is his contact me there.
Then they were like,
oh,
we want to send you some.
And so now there might be a coconut water bottle.
We should have like a taste test live and like big old.
Awesome.
Yeah,
they're both awesome.
I buy both of them all the time code.
I want her so good for you man.
Tastes so good too.
It's like it's not too sweet.
It's not,
you don't feel like you're drinking soda.
It's,
it feels super healthy.
It's naturally isotonic.
It's naturally good at rehydrating.
You have a coconut water question.
Hey,
I've been buying these other kinds like Zinco that they have at the grocery
store.
It's like a milk carton,
coconut water.
Right.
And the other day I passed out with it in bed and then uh,
next day I looked at him like,
Huh,
I'd probably just throw it in the frigerator has the word water in it,
you know.
Is that something that you can leave out?
Cause it's not like a milk.
It's like a water.
Well I assume that it could go bad because ants find it.
Well,
I mean the middle crazy.
Oh,
a sealed and we don't have ants.
You,
you have ants in your house?
I live in never,
I've never seen an aunt at my house ever.
Really?
Yeah.
Well it's cause the roaches eat the mall.
Um,
I live in the woods,
man.
I've got rats and dear of deer.
My Yard all at your aunt's here though are like,
like documentary style ants though that you have like parade,
gay parade.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
the Mile March hits,
this house is surrounded by land,
you know,
and there's not a lot of shit out there for them to eat.
And so when they find that they can get inside and get to the mother load in the
garbage pill,
you know,
or the either the,
it's either the garbage pail or a plate that's left around these mother fuckers,
one scout will find it.
That would be cool if ants had like really big ants.
Like it would be like a bunch of ants and then like a huge like,
like you know,
boss battle ant that would like walk with them.
Answer.
So terrifying man.
I was watching this documentary on the uh,
the heartbeat eagle.
Somebody put it up on a Sunday to see that monkey eating.
Dude,
if you haven't seen this,
you've got to look at,
you got to look it up online.
If you can't find it at all,
it's on my Twitter from probably from yesterday.
You'll find it just,
I tweet a lot unfortunately too.
I remember when you posted it.
I fall in the morning.
I was watching it.
I'm like,
my friend who was with him,
he was like that Joe is watching,
uh,
documentaries on my animals at four 30.
Dude,
I all I do,
this is what I do.
I stay up,
I read with my daughter when she goes to bed,
she goes to bed at like,
you know,
whatever.
So when she goes to bed,
I read for our readers a little stories and then I start writing.
So once everybody's asleep because Mrs Rogan's asleep,
everyone's asleep.
Then there's no,
there's no noise.
The dogs are fed,
the dogs are inside sleeping.
Then I can write.
So I write from like,
usually from like 10:00 PM is when I really get cracking till like two in the
morning I start getting tired.
Right.
You know,
so I bang out two hours,
you know,
four hours and then just chill out at midnight.
Shit's great.
I just need,
it seems like the only problem is,
is that I find myself going to the same seven websites,
10 websites over and over and over and over again.
You gotta be careful about that.
You gotta be careful if you're going to write you you.
That's why I love that that program I've talked about on the show,
right?
Right room,
right rooms the best because it doesn't allow you to access the message.
You know,
you don't get to look at the browser.
You know when you look at the status bar,
you don't look down at your task bar where all your programs are.
If you don't start fucking around and see what kind of movies do I have on this
hard drive.
Oh,
this is a cool documentary.
I haven't seen this before.
And then you'll just distract yourself with,
you got to force yourself to just write,
you know?
And once I do,
I love it.
It's such a weird thing about that,
about getting work done like that.
Like once when I write,
I'm like,
when I got something really that done that I,
that I really enjoy that I wrote like I feel so satisfied.
It feels like,
so like I'm like,
I feel energized.
I feel like I'm positive,
I feel good,
but it's so hard to just commit to working hard.
It is right.
It's hard to commit to sitting down and working when there's so many
distractions.
There's so many things you could do.
You know what the worst is,
especially like video editing is that you'd get to parts where it's like,
you know,
rendering and we'll say something like 30 minutes,
so you have to sit there for 30 minutes and you're not going to just sit there
and stare at the 30 minute sign.
You're going to look on the internet or you know what is and then you get
trapped in that.
What is like the baddest motherfucker rendering computer available?
Is it like some sort of a crazy PC with like multiple processes earlier?
Pretty much they all use the same chips honestly.
That like if you went balls crazy you'd want to get the,
in my opinion this is what I would do is get one of the towers from Mac and get
the,
they have like you know the quadruple process or whatever it is and that you
get,
they have it now we can have like 32 gigs of Ram and and but the bay,
the biggest thing,
the thing that I think would help the most is getting an SSD card,
a hard drive at for your operating system for your programs,
for everything because that's the biggest thing that I've noticed with crashing
and and just time consuming as the right read.
Right on the hard drives and how slow regular hard drives is compared to
compared to the SSD hard drives or SSD.
What Brian is talking about,
solid state hard drives,
which is basically very similar to when you get a flash drive,
like a USB drive,
you stick it in and you can just record.
That's like a little mini hard drive and the little ones now are way bigger than
the first hard drives that I had.
Totally.
I mean I got a 32 gigabyte one.
It's a little tiny thing that sticks in his 32 gigs.
My first hard drive was only four gigs.
Yeah.
If I could do like that's the thing I have the problem,
the biggest problem with mine is just the hard drive.
How much hard drive space,
uh,
in how fast that the rendering is.
And that's the thing you need to battle is rendering.
Yeah.
And so it's quicker to access off a solid state drive as well.
Oh yeah.
What you want those,
you want your applications running on it and you want like to have enough room
to have what projects and videos you're running off.
You want to run all off.
You understand the technology behind solid state as opposed to regular hard
drives.
Do you know which one does well,
there's no,
there's,
uh,
you know,
moving parts,
moving parts at all.
It's,
it's,
it's doing what's going on there.
I don't know.
That's the problem and magic.
Yeah,
man.
I mean that's dragging tears and super crazy magic.
This one is totally silent.
This one is a solid state.
Hard drive.
One.
It's so silent.
Yeah.
It never said,
and everything pulls up instantly.
It's amazing.
You know,
like the,
the read times as far as like,
you know,
my old hard drive used to have to boot up and you would hear like this little
spin going on and then the,
the,
you know,
the program and run,
like my really old,
I have an old,
old Mac book.
Really old.
It's fat like a fucking,
when you close it,
it's like an old book and you pop that Bitch Open and when you turn on you hear
things spinning and clicking and chunking.
Alex,
that's it.
This laptop
and the little old goofy looking,
you know,
like ancient cartoon looking apple logo pops up.
Yeah.
So the,
the,
the biggest one that apple offers is a 12 core 12 quartzy.
That's retarded processors.
That's retarded.
I wonder if you can,
if you select it,
I wonder if you can like jack it up even all four.
That's all for just like rendering.
I'm sure you can jack it up.
Like,
you know what sucks though,
is like the machine I use.
Um,
I uh,
used to have a 2020 inch monitors,
my main monitor,
which is pretty small.
And then it would have like this big monitor for editing videos for timeline as
was a 30 inch monitor.
So I just replaced the 20 inch monitor to the other day with this view sonic.
And so now I have a 27 inch and a 30 inch but my butt.
But for some reason that's too much HD display for my Mac.
So now my s my cursor just go so slow now across the screens it's,
it's like the graphics card can't handle it.
It sucks.
Well I went with everything that you could possibly get and there are $12,699.
Yo,
that's what the hard drive.
How big of a hard drive is that?
That is well nuts.
Not even with everything.
Cause I'll go with 30 gigs of memory,
32 gigs of memory and another thousand dollars and now we're up to $16,000.
You could get that memory cheaper.
Don't ever buy a memory from [inaudible] if you just wanted to get the big party
rolling,
but they'll do the hard drives.
That's all.
512 solid state,
512 512 foot 12 gigs.
And I got four of them that,
oh that's,
that's good.
I didn't know that they went up that high.
That was that would,
that would be a suite that you can get.
Like you can go and get a computer for fucking 500 bucks or you can get this
goddamn thing for 16,000 of you wanted to make your own.
That's the thing about windows though.
If you wanted to make your own computer that was equal in performance to this
computer,
you could probably do it for a tiny fraction of that money.
Really.
I mean cause I mean really,
I mean it's definitely going to be cheaper.
Like if if the smart thing to do is not to buy your SSD drives from apple,
you know you,
you get pretty much wanted to go to a store like Fry's electronics and pick up a
case and pick up hard drives and a motherboard and everything had put together
your own computer and make it to this kind of specifications.
How much you think of cost?
Well you,
if you had to guess it would be w 8,000 it would be pretty,
it would be pretty close.
No,
I actually would be pretty close because the fastest processor is still going to
be really expensive the fastest.
I mean that much ram,
it's still going to be pretty,
it's not going to be that much difference.
Like I think they priced out a macbook pro on someone like an Nan tech or
something like that.
They priced it out as like with the same like version of windows and it wasn't
that far off.
It was like 98 it was pretty close actually.
It's a Mac book pro.
This is like a high level tower where all we would do is you would just get the
bare bones processor,
whatever highest processes your wife don't get any as less ram as possible
through him as less hard drive space as possible for them.
You'd want to probably maybe even see what the graphics card option is,
go for the basic graphics card option and then buy all this shit separately.
But see this is maxed out though.
This is maxed out.
We're talking about Max that want the best hard drives,
right?
The best operating well with Vista video card.
Any,
any like alien ware or anything like that.
If you start maxing out different things,
they're like rent,
they're going to get you on Ram.
That's like when you buy something and they give you extras and they totally
know what you're saying about ordering from big companies.
But what I'm saying is that if you want to do it on your own,
if you wanted to go to your arm,
no idea.
I have no idea.
I haven't built a computer and six years.
It is kind of crazy though that you know.
So,
I mean the big percentage of the population in the country and the world rather
uses windows,
right?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean something like 70 or 80% than everybody that uses computers has windows.
Right.
But meanwhile they could viruses.
Yeah.
Have you ever heard of anybody getting a virus when you have an apple?
No.
To amps.
I know they exist.
Cunt bag pain in the ass are viruses.
That's the biggest fucking pain in the ass ever.
I mean,
I have had so many people on,
on the message board say,
you know when they're,
they're scared of clicking a link.
Like I'm not clicking that.
I want to click on that.
I've never looked at something and said,
I'm not clicking that right.
Cause I'm not worried about losing my shit.
That's one of the best things about apples and I'm sure everyone's going to
start screaming.
They haven't invented them.
My favorite thing also is that,
that see what the PC is.
I used to build pcs most of my life.
I would get this graphics card,
this motherboard,
this memory,
this hard drive,
this,
this net.
The problem is that that windows has to have every be able to work on all these
variations of hard drives and different kinds of graphics cards.
Like it has to be super programmed for all these different combos with apple,
apple programs.
Exactly.
For the hardware it uses,
there's not a thousand different,
um,
graphics cards that go into the motherboard that,
that works in the apple,
you know,
so they got an apple motherboard or what they call it,
logic board,
which means it's more
expensive.
Totally know what you're saying to me.
They give you less choices.
And because of that,
they build it all themselves.
So there's more fine tuned as an operating system on top of it because of the
hardware is apple hardware is what it is.
But there's something pretty dope about being able to go,
I used to love making my own computers.
I've,
I've done it at least twice where I went and got the whole deal motherboard
case,
put it all together,
spent,
you know,
God,
who knows how many hours,
but when you're actually finally online with some computer that you made
yourself,
that's pretty dope.
Yeah.
There's something fucking cool,
dude.
It was,
I'm like erector set style.
It's something bad ass about the fact that it's so cheap that you don't have to
do that anymore though.
I know,
but it's fun.
It's something fun to it.
Is it something super satisfying?
Like Dunkin has one of my computers but there's some super satisfying,
I put that shit together and I install the operating system.
You know,
I,
I tweaked the registry,
right.
I went into the Bios,
remember the,
what is it that are not the things you brought up?
Spacers.
What are those things that confuses or what are those things that used to have
to put out those were the worst because that it was like,
Oh do you have to uh,
yeah,
the tweezers to pull them in and it had to be different combos.
Like yeah,
there's a lot of annoying shit about making computers
either like the shit would go into the bio's and having to change the frequency
down or the ramp cache size if you have a different kind of graphics card.
So many annoying little,
yeah.
How about dudes who would go into their full bios and overclocked or motherboard
and then it was just slight tweaking.
Like dudes would buy celeron processors and tweak them so that they performed
like an intel,
like a pentium processor.
Sirens first came out and I was like that diet coke of computers was like
something missing,
but dudes would overclock the shit out of him and play quake with them.
Right.
Cause it was like super cheap.
There was even a few companies online that would overclock shit for you.
So they would build it for you.
Like super jacked,
like some super jacked giant heat sink on it.
Fans blowing all over it.
We,
they've got this poor little poor little a processor going just everything's
like jack to the Max,
like much higher than it's supposed to be.
Yeah.
The whole thing is interesting how quickly it's evolved from when I first got my
first computer,
it was a penny two 400 so it was a 400 megahertz.
Now is three 86 [inaudible] five three 86 three 86 how many megahertz is at
three 26 is it 380
yeah.
Then it goes up to four 86 was my upgrade.
I was like,
Oh my God,
I've got a 46 wow.
Amazing.
Well,
I remember,
um,
when,
when I first got,
it was like the top of the line.
It was a micron,
you know,
this is my first PC that I got and I remember thinking,
like,
wow,
you all this power and all this space and all this.
Now it's not even close to what your phone does.
Right.
That's amazing.
You know,
my phone has 32 gigs of space on it.
My first hard drive had four 32 gigs and my first first computer was 400
megahertz.
This is a thousand and it's in your pocket and it's thin as you know,
like a notebook.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
We live in strange ass times,
man.
We really do.
You know,
they can't put this guy in jail for this hacking his wife's fucking email now.
That's retarded.
Goddamn,
that's legit too,
right?
Oh yeah.
To know a hundred different sites.
It's legit.
It's on Fox News Son.
It's a Michigan man faces five years in prison.
If convicted of felony charges of hacking into his wife's email,
Leon Walker,
33 was busted after he accessed his wife,
Clara is account and discovered she was having an affair.
I love the account.
And then the big dash and discovered she was having an affair.
How does he not,
how does he go to jail on the whore?
Doesn't whore.
You need to go to drill whore.
Give me the baby,
give me the baby and go learn.
You need to go read books and do pushups.
You can't just fucking can't just go fuck your ex husband.
You Yukon.
Yeah,
with my baby can go over there.
Crazy whore.
So what's up message say to you Brian,
does it say don't hack into people's shit or does it say don't get caught?
Uh,
well if you're married and you have good reason to believe that your wife is
cheating on you,
then yes.
Get the upper hand so you know what's going on first.
You know gay,
cause that's marriage is different.
You want to have all your bases covered.
You want to,
it's like an attack plan
spoken like a man who's experienced some crazy bitches.
Yeah
and always turn out.
Turn on your record feature on your phone when you're fighting just in case
something gets crazy and you need proof.
How about how crazy have you ever had it?
Fun.
We've talked about it.
I've done a jail and if I had
cell phones back then,
you know I would have been fucking recording night shit.
You would have been free.
It'd be a Freebie.
A free man.
Well,
I mean I was free already,
but it just took me money in a year and a half of court.
Isn't that crazy?
One nutty bitch blows one fuse one day and it affects you for,
you know,
a percentage of your life.
A year and a half.
It's like $10,000 to $12,000 and I fucking made like $40 a day.
Think about that.
If you live the perfect life and you lived a long,
long,
healthy life,
one year,
that's 1% of your life.
You had to give up 1% of the lie of dealing with this chick's bullshit.
Yeah.
My fucking job wouldn't even let me take off time anymore for the court.
I had to go to court like every couple of weeks,
you know,
it seemed like I can't,
I know it might be exaggerating a little bit.
I think I went to court like for 12 to 14 times and I remember having to always
call off work and they were,
they got to a point where like we can't give you any more fucking time.
You know we're going to have to replace you.
And I actually had to like find people that have worked for me.
Mother fucker.
Right.
All for just some nutty broad and nothing happened.
It's just craziness.
Just made up fantasy.
Actually didn't even pick up the charges.
She just said she got in a fight with her boyfriend and she,
I kicked her out of the house and the city picked up the charges cause there's
like the Oj Simpson law,
something like that.
Oh Jay costs you dude fucking Oj.
That's amazing.
If you lived a healthy life,
you'd be a 100 right?
A great life,
a great long life.
You're about a guide now.
He was a hundred you go,
wow,
that kind of lived a good life.
That's 1% of a hundred is a year.
Right?
That's craziness,
dude.
He gave up 1% of your life,
you know,
and then she's trying to add me on Facebook like a year and a half ago and I'm
like,
are you fucking kidding me?
That's hilarious.
What are you gonna do?
Like take pictures if I poke you.
Did she ever apologize?
Did she said she felt the day that that court dropped the charges and all that
or everything like that.
They were like,
you know,
dropped all the charges.
She wrote me or she called me and I have it on my voicemail.
I had it on my voice mail back in the day,
or answering machine back in the day where she's like,
I'm so sorry about everything.
You know?
I really hope that we can hang out soon and I just want you to know I'm very
sorry for her.
I didn't do any of this.
The state did it and blah,
blah.
You know what the crazy called the comps in the first place?
Huh?
She called the cops?
Yeah,
because what happened is I went and drive her home at night.
I kicked her out of my house.
I was like,
fuck you,
you're breaking my house after in the street.
I just shut her.
I just pushed her out the front doors and let the door.
No,
it's,
I don't know.
It was like,
did you expect her to get home?
Um,
I didn't care.
She was breaking shit in my house.
I was like,
fuck her.
You get the fuck out of my house.
You know,
she was going crazy.
You should have called the cops at that point.
Then I should have,
I should know smashing my shit.
I want her out of here.
I should have put to me,
I was so pissed off that I just went upstairs and just went to bed because it
was like 2:00 AM or something like that.
So she called the cops and what did she tell the cops?
She said that my boyfriend and I had gotten an argument,
he pushed me out of the house and then when and drive me home and the officers
or what do you mean post?
Cause I actually did,
she wouldn't leave my house.
I opened the front door and I pushed her out,
not like fall on the ground,
you know,
or anything like that.
It was more like get on this side of the door,
all right,
door shut,
you know,
type of push and uh,
and the officer's like,
oh he pushed you,
he wouldn't drive you home.
And so they unlawful restraint.
They,
they got a blue one of the cops.
No,
but it was a girl cop.
But what was crazy is that when the,
when the beginning of the court case,
I don't think I've ever said this part,
whenever went to court case they made,
made you go to an anger therapist,
like a court appointed anger therapists where they just ask you questions to see
if you're crazy or not or you know,
or angry,
you know,
is that psychologists,
psychologists and then halfway through that guy he goes,
I'm sorry.
I am going to have to stop.
I actually know the other person that you did this with.
I went to high school with her and uh,
I'm going to have to have my assistant take on the rest of this interview.
And so the guy,
I'm like,
wait,
that's not fair.
This guy went to high school with her and said this other guy walks in and sits
down and goes because you know,
we continue to,
we leave and then yeah,
they told the court like,
oh yeah,
he's crazy.
He's angry,
he's mad and blah blah blah.
And so then I had to get a lawyer just to like tell the judge like that's not
fair that that the person went to high school with her that come on,
give me a break.
You got off of it though.
And then he brought in his friend.
Yeah.
But the debrief is friend and W.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So you think that he's like go after this Douche bag.
Well,
absolutely.
If you worked as a psychiatrist in your buddy from high school games and you're
probably going to be how on your side,
your buddy of your group that's especially if you were in love with it.
Right.
And especially as but anyways,
so we had to like go to court like three times and then like just to get the
judge to say,
okay that's bullshit yet we'll give you another psychiatrist to go to.
So of course I went to the other psychiatrists and they're like,
oh yeah,
he's fine.
He's completely normal.
And then they dropped all the charges.
Actually said that there was something wrong with you.
The first person where it's like they said that he's angry.
I could see that he will revolt in anger and will be fired.
Yeah.
I know.
I know this,
but this is also like what 10 years ago,
his name,
it was like 10 years ago.
I hadn't even not have that burned into your brain.
It was actually more than Texas.
I was 19 I would be making videos about that guy every day now.
Yeah.
Now that if I knew it for some high school pussy,
that's what it was.
High school chick that he was in love with and he wanted to get you locked in a
cage,
show her,
I could come and rescue you,
Brian,
right?
Or girl,
whatever her name is.
I called her you.
What is her name?
I'm not saying,
you know what I'm saying?
No content.
Mcgillicuddy healthy person when contraception.
And on that note,
ladies and gentlemen,
that's always a good way to end to show,
oh,
by the way,
a Joe and team,
we're having a UFC broadcast a Saturday with Joey Diaz and Sam Tripoli and we're
going to be,
what is the a Ustream,
a address.
Um,
it's going to be on my Twitter,
but it will be a Ustream.
Dot.
I don't have a fancy use during like,
you know,
it's Ustream dot.
TV backslash Red Bang.
This is what you do is go to Twitter and look up red band already.
D B,
a n not red band.
It's a different person now.
Red Ban,
gay band and a,
if you do that,
you'll find the Twitter.
They did it before.
Um,
during the last UFC they watched the UFC,
they order it on paper view and then they sit there and talk about it while it's
going on and talk shit.
And it's a lot of fun.
And in between fights,
like if you're watching the fights and like,
you know,
a lot of times in between fights it's like,
you get bored or you,
you know,
you want to go get some food.
Well if you can have this going on at the same time you have a bunch of standup
comedians giving commentary and Joey Diaz is going to be there and who else is
going to be there?
Tripoli,
Sam Aaa.
Maybe he might stop,
come on son.
Just,
just that alone.
Joey Diaz,
Sam Tripoli and Jason [inaudible] and they're all going to be doing comedy
commentary on the UFC and drinking like crazy drinking and smoking dope with two
hands.
And we're going to be twittering.
You trying to bug you and I'm going to be Twitter.
I'm going to be texting them.
I can't Twitter while I'm out there because I don't want to give away spoilers
and shit,
but I'll,
I'll text Brian so Brian will have the inside skinny dirty bitches and uh,
if you also want to see Joey Diaz,
he is going to be with me February 4th.
We're doing a show in Vegas at the Mandalay Bay theater.
It's some new badass theater at Mandalay Bay and it's me,
Orisha fear and Joey Coco Diaz tickets are flying off the shelves,
bitches.
I think,
uh,
the front areas already gone.
Uh,
but it's February for that.
You can buy tickets online.
If you go to Joe rogan.net.
There's a link,
right?
Yep.
You can click on that shit.
Just click on a banner on the side and a,
so this Thursday we're having another podcast and it was with a house sparks and
that should be very interesting because how's a very bright guy with a very
varied career.
He has a rock band.
It's called zero one.
So he'll be our Thursday guest.
And thank you very much everybody who made this podcast top 10 and the iTunes
list,
that means the world to me and Brian,
right?
Brian?
Yes.
We're excited.
Thank you.
We're going to figure out a way to do something with this and make it bigger.
We're going to take this shit to the next level in 2011 folks is officially one
year since we started,
so this is our last show.
Should have been our one year show,
but it was a day off.
It was the 23rd.
This is it.
This is really it.
We've gone full year.
All right,
bitches.
You know I love you.
You know Brian loves you.
R E d.
B,
a n on Twitter.
Follow him because he's very upset at his Twitter account.
It's just really lagging.
Comparatives is,
is progressing compared to yours.
Tensions is Christ.
I just want at least 8% of your people,
um,
ball in a ball and on Twitter.
I'm not balling 500,000.
His ball and I'm half ball and I'm like,
copper records.
I got a copper record.
I need,
I need to get a gold snicky numbers.
Stokey numbers.
It'd be spectacular.
I need a Goddamn TV show.
That's what you gotta do.
You gotta get a TV show and TV show,
pumps up your Twitter and that pumps hyper stand up comedy shows that and
produce more comedy.
That's all happening.
It looks like my next comedy specials going to be filmed in Toronto.
Buckle the fuck up.
You dirty Canadian bitches cause I'm coming.
I had such a good time last time I was in Toronto and in those is going to be a
UFC in Toronto in April.
So it looks like that's where I'm planning on doing my next Special Holla at
your boy.
That's an April.
Yes.
All right.
Dirty bitches.
Mandalay bay,
February 4th be there.
Joe Diaz,
rh fear.
Brian Red Band will be in tendons and an epic video will be made probably better
than the one that's out right now from Austin.
The Austin one is available right now and youtube.
Go find it on Joe Rogan.
That's my channel.
I've said too much.
I'm tired of listening to my own fucking voice.
Good eye
mandate of a war against the American people.
Yep.
Tyranny is enveloping the globe and the United States is a shining jewel.
The globalist want to bring down and they will use terrorism as a pretext to get
it done.
So that's coming up in the second half of the show.
Very important information.
I'm going to put the call out that you call the White House and tell him,
look,
we've seen the new stories that you've wanted to blow things out,
that you have blown things up and that you're saying that 4 million of us are
going to die and we need martial law and the Associated Press
at one of your little drills you had,
this is Paris.
This is Alex Jones talking aware of who the terrorists are.
You can pull this,
this can stop the Shit Larian Reichstag event.
Maybe,
maybe just him
tangle as a slam dunk.
What'd you do?
It's not the heart of this dog.
There wasn't a real [inaudible] a warning on the clock to move ball,
another beat to soul strong.
Hold on and not get wicked.